[Musique]
Emma Aziza bonsoir nous vous recevons
pour une chaîne internet qui s'appelle
thinkerview nous sommes en direct est-ce
que vous pouvez vous présenter
succinctement
c'est-à-dire je travaille sur les
sciences de l'eau et j'essaye de
comprendre tout ce qui est en
interaction finalement avec l'eau dans
le monde donc ça peut être la qualité de
l'eau la quantité d'eau ça peut être des
inondations les sécheresses
les crues éclairs les plus torrentiels
en fait de quelle manière l'eau va
tomber sur le sol quel va être son
chemin et qu'elle va être son usage
derrière donc en fait c'est un champ
tellement vaste que 18 ans après j'en
apprends encore tous les jours et en fin
de compte tu te rends surtout compte que
tout ce que tu sais c'est que tu sais
rien tellement en réalité il y a à
prendre en hydrologie tout ce que je
sais c'est que je ne sais
faire venir aujourd'hui
parce que on s'intéresse au fondamentaux
de soutenabilité de notre modèle de
société et on s'intéresse comme tu peux
le voir aussi new noir et le signe noir
c'est quelque chose que on n'a pas vu
venir mais qui change tout et en général
ce qu'on n'a pas vu venir c'est qu'on
voulait pas le voir venir
et donc sur l'hydrologie tu es ingénieur
hydrologue et nous on veut parler de
plein de choses qui ont des
répercussions sur la nourriture sur les
marchés financiers sur la santé des gens
sur la concentration des saloperies
qu'il y a dans les nappes phréatiques la
pollution des eaux l'affaissement des
sols les problèmes de rendement mais son
âge a parlé tu veux commencer par quoi
comment tu veux faire prendre conscience
à une société
qu'une épée de mots clés c'est au-dessus
de nos têtes alors qui sont pas foutus
de respecter le code de la route ils ont
juste rien à faire
tu peux le voir encore à l'heure
actuelle comment on fait quand on a une
société un modèle capacité
capitalistique immature basée sur une
société de transformant doper depuis des
décennies avec du neuro-marketing pour
exciter les zones les plus primitives du
cerveau du consommateur quand on voit
que notre système éducatif ne forme plus
des gens à penser mais des gens à
consommer et encore je reste
gentil alors comment on fait toi qui en
fait en première ligne du réchauffement
climatique de parler de nectu tu peux
brasser
c'est dur comme introduction non mais
écoute je vais essayer d'y répondre je
sais vrai que c'est une équation un peu
insoluble parce que tu te dis que
en fait on est tous face au même futur
tu vois comment et en réalité ce que je
me dis c'est qu'effectivement
face à des systèmes qui ont manipulé nos
subconscients et qui calcule autant de
cerveau permanent en réalité je pense
que le seul moyen c'est d'essayer que
chacun reprenne son pouvoir et pour
pouvoir reprendre son pouvoir le seul
moyen c'est d'essayer d'augmenter notre
niveau de conscience et pas de manquer
notre niveau de conscience sur ce qui se
passe à l'autre bout de la planète qui
semble ne pas nous intéresser parce que
c'est comme ça d'abord qu'on a parlé du
climat en France à chaque fois qu'on
parlait du climat on montrait un glacier
on montrait un ours blanc et donc on
expliquait aux gens que ce pauvre ours
blanc finalement il était en fait sur
son iceberg en train de fondre ça généré
chez nous de la frustration de la colère
de l'impuissance et en réalité tu sais
pas par quoi commencer tu sais pas où
agir tu sais pas ce qu'il faut faire et
quand tu regardes derrière les Dixie
d'ailleurs en Californie tu regardes les
feux incontrôlables en Australie en fait
tu as l'impression à la fois que c'est
très très loin et je crois qu'on a eu ce
biais cognitif d'avoir le sentiment
qu'on était un peu dans la Punité ou
rien ne nous arriverait parce qu'on fait
partie d'un pays riche parce qu'on est
un pays tempéré la France est vraiment
le centre entre un pays humide avec la
Belgique au nord et un pays sec m'y
arrive voire aride dès que tu descends
vers le sud et nous on essaie de
ceinture cette ceinture on la voyait
venir tu regardes les premiers rapports
du GIEC en 2001 ils te disent très
clairement le problème des sécheresses
se posera sur le pourtour climatique et
le pourtour méditerranéen donc
effectivement
on était persuadé que il y aurait un
problème sur un morceau si tu veux de
notre métropole espèce d'Arc mais
finalement que le reste n'allait pas
avoir de problème majeurs et le deuxième
problème qu'on a eu dans cette manière
de concevoir le climat c'est que tout le
monde nous a un peu expliqué via des
derrière très pédagogique que la
température qui aura ses vies finalement
en 2030 2050 et la température qu'on
aura à Bordeaux et puis finalement ce
qu'on exploité à Bordeaux le Merlot les
cavernes des Sauvignon talait
l'exploiter plutôt en Champagne et puis
qu'ensuite tu as les remonter comme ça
et en fait on se rend compte que ça
marche pas du tout comme ça déjà
l'évolution climatique elle évolue pas
comme ça en remontant naturellement de
manière aussi simplifiée déjà c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué et puis tu
regardes rien que cette année en fait on
démarre une année historiquement
en tous les cas avec une projection à
scénario climatique qui sont quand même
assez mal barré pour cet été parce qu'on
a aucune recharge hivernale de nos nappe
mais pas que nous c'est à dire que la
Belgique démarre à 95% de son territoire
avec des sols extrêmement secs donc en
réalité c'est plus une question de pays
tempéré de pays non tempérés c'est une
question de déficit de pluie ou est-ce
qu'il manque de la pluie ou est-ce qu'il
manque de l'eau et comment se renouvelle
ou ne se renouvelle pas et donc en fait
du coup ça pose effectivement les
questions de comment on a aménagé nos
territoires aménager nos sols et ce
changement climatique qui vient révéler
toutes nos erreurs tout ce qu'on a
justement pas fait et donc maintenant
les gens sont en train de comprendre que
on est plus focalisé sur l'ours blanc
alors on a encore quasiment tous les
sujets climatiques qui nous montrent
encore un iceberg et je crois qu'il
faudrait peut-être arrêter parce qu'il
va nous falloir montrer peut-être la
Belgique ou le Canada parce que le
Canada vit des canicules historiques le
Canada commence à irriguer
tu vois le grand géant de l'eau mondial
quand tu traverses une rivière au Canada
tu as l'impression de traverser une mer
tellement si gigantesque et en réalité
ils ont des fentes nivales ou des Fonts
de neige beaucoup plus rapidement qui
vont se croiser avec des risques de crus
donc ils découvrent en fin de compte
alors qu'ils ont toujours été soumis aux
risques inondations ils découvrent qui
sont hyper exposés qu'on a absolument
pas réfléchi sur le plan urbanistique et
surtout il se sentait complètement
déconnecté du risque de sécheresse et ça
ça vaut pour le Canada ça vaut pour le
Brésil le Brésil a fondé toute son
système énergétique sur les barrages
hydroélectriques 61% de son électricité
vient de se barrage le problème c'est
que quand tu as plus d'eau dans ses
barrages qu'est-ce que tu fais et donc
des barrages tu en as des dizaines de
milliers partout dans le monde et qui
sont construits encore en permanence
tout le temps partout parce que en fait
on cherche à maîtriser l'eau depuis que
l'homme a compris qu'en fin de compte sa
survit dépendait de du fait de contrôler
l'eau de contrôler l'hygiène de
contrôler l'adduction d'eau potable pour
les populations de contrôler
l'agriculture et ben il est rentré dans
un système complètement fou où il a
oublié qu'il faisait partie du cycle
naturel il s'est complètement déconnecté
et donc je pourrais continuer comme ça
sur sur plein d'exemples mais
ce que je veux te dire pour essayer de
répondre à ta question par où on
commence mais on commence par la prise
de conscience qu'on concernés que ça
concerne pas que les autres que ça nous
concerne nous qu'en 2019 il y avait des
feux de champs en Picardie tu imagines
ce que ça signifie des feux de champ en
Picardie c'est-à-dire que j'ai été
audité par le ministère d'intérieur qui
m'expliquait qui mettait entre 3 et 5
ans pour commander un Canadair entre les
appels d'offres etc aujourd'hui toutes
les colonnes de sapeurs-pompiers
viennent renfort sur le pourtour
méditerranéen la Corse l'été ils sont
pas là pour gérer les Hauts-de-France
pour gérer la Picardie ou la Normandie
et en fait ce que nous montre
l'évolution et la cinétique de ce qui
est en train de se passer c'est que
c'est autant là que ça va se passer
qu'ailleurs
donc ça c'est quelque chose d'absolument
nouveau et je crois qu'on est moins prêt
beaucoup plus vulnérable quand on n'est
pas adapté parce que justement en
contexte méditerranéen on a pris
l'habitude d'avoir des extrêmes
thermiques très importants
tous les anciens grandissaient derrière
avec des murs de pierre comme ça les
volets fermés jusqu'à 16h avec la sieste
tu avais un mode de vie qui allait avec
et donc en réalité ils ont toujours été
adaptés notamment au niveau de leur
corps au niveau de leur système
cardiovasculaire tout leur toute leur
organisme en fin de compte et est adapté
à ces températures mais ceux qui ne sont
pas adaptés ceux qui ont vécu dans un
autre système et qui voit arriver ce
changement climatique avec une vitesse
qu'on n'avait jamais vu et ben à ce
moment là effectivement c'est cela les
plus fragiles parce que en fait le
rythme avec lequel les choses arrivent
dépassent même l'entendement de ce qu'on
peut imaginer c'est-à-dire que
l'être humain c'est sans doute celui qui
sait le plus adapté au changement
climatique parce que quand tu regardes
partout dans le monde on sait on s'est
installé dans les toundras dans les
déserts on s'est installé partout sur la
planète donc on est capable de
s'installer mais il faut un moment donné
une période d'adaptation il faut adapté
la manière notre bâtille derrière la
manière dont on va construire on va
prendre en considération notre
environnement et donc en fait on s'est
installé un peu partout sauf qu'on a
basculé ces dernières années sur un
modèle ou derrière la seule chose qui
nous importe c'est les retraites et
c'est le fait d'avoir un bien immobilier
dont la moyenne à peu près française
c'est 22 ans et demi je regardais les
coûts des prêts le temps de prêt
immobilier en 22 ans et demi il peut se
passer énormément de choses sur ta
maison
comprendre sur 7 ans il y en a d'autres
qui empruntent sur 30 ans
mais du coup c'est intéressant cette
moyenne parce que du coup ça nous montre
que on projette derrière l'achat d'un
bien et ce qu'on est fait pour être sé
est-ce que aujourd'hui on peut encore se
le permettre avec les effets en chaîne
l'augmentation du niveau des mers et des
Océans
un effet en Chine une boucle de
rétroaction donne-moi explique-nous ce
que c'est un effet
domino c'est ce que tu avais pas vu
venir et c'est le risque qui cachait
derrière c'est le tsunami il faut
kushima derrière pour moi c'est l'effet
domino le plus parlant personne n'avait
imaginé un risque nucléaire avec un
tsunami et donc souvent j'entends quand
j'essaye d'évoquer la question du
nucléaire en relation avec l'eau
les gens me dis oui mais bon on a aussi
des centrales derrière en bord de mer
derrière on a aucun problème il faut
peut-être pas oublier qu'en mer du Nord
à peu près au 15e 16e siècle on a eu un
tsunami qui a tout ravagé et en réalité
on est absolument pas derrière le fameux
risque zéro n'existe pas c'est une
réalité la seule chose quand on gère les
risques et quand on gère les crises
c'est qu'on sait juste qu'on sait rien
c'est la seule chose
je travaille en cellule de crise pendant
des années je peux t'assurer quand tu
fais fermer ou une autoroute parce que
derrière tu as des pluies diluviennes tu
sais pas ce qui va se passer quand un
jour j'ai fait fermer le préfet m'a
écouté ce jour-là parce que je
travaillais en cellule préfectorale
quand il y avait des événements majeurs
d'inondation dans le sud de la France et
quand j'ai expliqué aux préfet derrière
qu'on avait un cellule orageuse qui
restait bloquée sur l'autoroute qu'on
était dans une zone de cuvette entre
Nîmes et Montpellier et qu'il fallait
absolument évacuer la population il m'a
écouté il a fait fermer l'autoroute à
neuf dans les deux sens ce qui était des
premières décisions qui avaient jamais
été prise en 30 ans et on a des routes
4000 voitures
1h30 après il y avait un mètre 72 sur
l'autoroute on est passé à côté d'une
catastrophe il y a eu aucune victime
donc en réalité ça aurait pu se passer
comme ça ça aurait pu se passer
autrement il y a quelques mois cette
même autoroute s'est retrouvée dans les
mêmes circonstances avec une
pluviométrie intense et là par contre on
a eu des gens complètement bloqué sur
l'autoroute et heureusement qu'on a eu
des élites rouillage à temps donc en
fait je crois que quand tu te confrontes
entre les projections à très longues
distances de l'évolution climatique de
la réalité de la complexité du monde et
puis les décisions qu'on doit prendre
dans des temps très courts c'est là où
tu te confrontes à tous les biacognitifs
humains qui font que et ça vraiment je
l'ai vu en temps de crise quand la crise
est là tu as beau avoir préparé les
choses à l'avance tu peux avoir des
plans planifier l'urbanisme expliquer
aux gens faire des campagnes de
sensibilisation essayez de réfléchir à
tout et c'est ce qui a été fait beaucoup
pour le risque inondation quand
l'événement est là on n'y croit pas
tu vois parce qu'on est là et on se dit
non c'est pas possible non non mais ça
va concerner les autres ça va pas nous
concerner on a on a du mal à imaginer
que ça va arriver sur nous et donc ça je
te dis ça à l'échelle d'une cellule de
crise alors imagine à l'échelle lambda
on a toujours l'impression que on se dit
à les pauvres on a découvert si on prend
par exemple le cas du risque inondation
on a découvert en France qu'on était
soumise au risque inondations
quand on a eu raison la romaine on a
tous petits été choqués par moi j'étais
petite à ce moment-là 1992 et donc on a
tous été sous les eaux c'était quoi 88
d'abord alors Nîmes ça va être vraiment
un choc de des gens parce que du coup on
découvre qu'on est soumis au cru éclair
et surtout on va avoir jusqu'à 2 mètres
d'eau dans la dans la ville on va avoir
des rumeurs qui vont se propager qu'on
cacherait les morts parce qu'en réalité
c'est pas possible qui est pas qui est
que 11 morts au final en plus on a eu
que 9 et on a eu deux qui ven
l'hélicoptère justement pour pour
inquiéter pas directement mort derrière
de des inondations et puis arrive d'un
seul coup vision la Romaine et là c'est
le choc parce que en fait tu vois un
cours d'eau qui fait 20 cm de hauteur
qui va monter à 10 mètres de hauteur en
4 heures
et ça et ben en fait personne a voulu
pouvoir venir tu as un météorologue qui
a vu la pluviométrie qui a commencé à
prévenir et toute la chaîne de
commandement qui a pas suivi parce
qu'ils ont pas compris parce qu'ils ont
pas ils ont ils sont pas intégré le fait
que ça pouvait être aussi violent et
puis surtout que ça allait arriver sur
un petit cours d'eau qui s'appelle
louvaise ou juste à Laval tu venais de
construire un super lotissement tout
neuf qui avait été livré 6 mois avant et
tu as eu des dizaines de morts dans ce
lotissement qui ont été complètement
gloutis par les flots et c'est là on a
commencé à prendre conscience ah bah
peut-être falloir prendre attention
enfin faire attention à l'urbanisme
des pensées ou parce qu'ils avaient
envie d'anticiper c'est que le maire qui
a signé le permis de construire
le risque inondation derrière ils
avaient pas intégré l'ampleur des flots
localement
juste pour rebondir tu vois la tiner la
Vésubie la Roya derrière ça a dépassé
les zones inondables on est dans la en
plus tu rajoutes la couche changement
climatique donc tu rajoutes le fait que
au lieu d'avoir 250 mm d'eau donc 250
litres d'eau par mètre carré tu imagines
à peu près une baignoire par mètre carré
et ben tu en as deux parce que tu as 500
mm et donc en réalité bah c'est tout un
moment donné va tout dévaster sur son
passage et puis en plus tu as vraiment
le fond du lit même du cours d'eau de la
Vésubie qui est monté de trois mètres en
sédiment c'est à dire que à la fin tu
avais plus que 4 mètres de hauteur mais
en réalité c'était 7 mètres plus haut
donc en réalité c'est resté à 7 mètres
toute la nuit donc en fait en matière
d'inondation on est dans de l'ordre de
l'impensable et mais on a toujours
tendance à réagir après crise
c'est-à-dire que la gestion des
politiques publiques et la manière dont
on va mettre en place ensuite des lois
essayer d'initier des choses et ben ça
se fait après les crises et quelque part
la France a de la chance sur le risque
inondation on verra sur la sécheresse
après parce que comme on a une hymne
Vaison-la-Romaine l'Aude en 1999 les
le gars en 2002 2003-205 tu as une série
en fait les politiques ont évolué très
rapidement et on a 20 ans d'avance sur
ces politiques là par rapport au reste
du monde quand tu vas au Canada ils nous
ont regardé comme si on était le Père
Noël parce que derrière enfin de compte
ils en sont qu'au balbutiements ils sont
à peine en train de cartographier leur
liste pour te donner un ordre d'idée et
je te parle d'une ville comme Montréal
c'est pas derrière une ville qui est
planquée au fin fond du désert derrière
c'est une grande ville qui a les moyens
et on est à peine en train de prendre en
compte les risques donc et sur le risque
sécheresse en fait on l'a pas vu venir
et on n'était pas prêt on n'était pas
prêt parce que derrière ça fait cinq ans
qu'on a des sécheresses historiques à
chaque fois ces différents chaque année
on a beaucoup d'eau l'hiver voire même
des fois des années excédentaires parce
qu'on a des grandes inondations 2018 on
a eu l'usine inondations de la scène et
donc on démarre l'été plutôt assez
confiant sauf que on se prend une vague
de chaleur ou une canicule et ça génère
une de sécheresse éclair qui va
transformer le territoire en l'espace de
15 jours une semaine et en fait à ce
moment-là ta chute des rendements
agricoles tu as tous les cours d'eau qui
s'effondre les nappes phréatiques aussi
on bascule dans un système de crise
généralisée et là on l'avait pas vu
venir et chaque année on recommence en
disant on essayera mieux l'année
prochaine derrière on démarre bien parce
qu'on a tendance à oublier et je trouve
que le plus dangereux c'est 2021 parce
que 2021 il a plu sur quasiment toute la
métropole pourquoi parce que tu as eu
tellement de masse d'air chaudes bloqués
sur la Scandinavie tu avais un énorme
anticyclone et puis un moment donné des
que le vortex polaire c'est c'est en
fait si tu veux
un moment donné à générer une goût de
froide cette goutte froide c'est une
anomalie thermique très haut en dans
l'atmosphère qui va générer des
dépressions on en a eu 6 de gouttes
froides successives à peu près
positionnés sur l'Atlantique vers la
Bretagne et donc en fait de générer
l'arrivée d'air froid qui ont et qui ont
ensuite rencontré l'air chaud de la mer
Méditerranée et l'air de la mère
Adriatique et puis ça a donné quoi comme
l'air il était la dépression était
contrainte de remonter en direction de
l'Allemagne et de la Belgique pourquoi
parce que bloqué par l'anticyclone de la
Scandinavie ça a donné les inondations
qu'on a eu donc en réalité on a eu en
Belgique et en Allemagne mais qu'on
aurait très bien pu avoir en France il
aurait suffi de décaler le système
dépressionnaire pour qu'on vive la même
chose enfin de compte on a eu beaucoup
de chance et on a eu un été maussade
gris plus vieux et quand tu regardes
juste la zone qui était pas dans cette
bulle bleue tu as l'Aude l'Hérault les
Pyrénées-Orientales le Var et là tu te
rends compte que c'est des systèmes qui
ont été complètement très secs et
surtout on a des villages qu'on
alimentait en camion citerne parce qu'il
y avait plus d'eau dans les villages
parce que parce qu'on additionné quatre
années de sécheresse historique et puis
tallevard où il y a eu des feux
incontrôlables
et donc ça pose la question du fait que
toute cramer tout autour tu as Athènes
qui arrivait pas à gérer ses feux tu as
l'Algérie qui pareil qui a eu des feux
ingérables et puis tu en même temps tu
vois la Sicile était à 48,2 degrés en
fin de compte tu avais un dôme de
chaleur sur l'Espagne tout était chaud
mais la France était dans sa Bible et on
a eu un peu l'impression que finalement
en terme de politique de sécheresse on
va pouvoir prendre le temps on va monter
des comités on va faire des rapports on
va essayer d'analyser d'évoluer mais en
fait on n'a pas compris on n'a pas
compris parce que parce qu'en fait il
faut réagir tout de suite parce que même
si tu plantes un arbre derrière dans
trois ans il fera un mètre 50 maximum
mais encore derrière ça dépend quel
arbre tu plantes et puis je suis pas sûr
que cette Herblay puisse tenir avec les
nouvelles températures donc il va
falloir faire des tests il y a des
choses qui fonctionneront il y a des
choses qui fonctionneront pas mais il
faut tester partout massivement et donc
ça pose la question de qu'est-ce qu'on a
fait pendant toutes ces années qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé pendant les trentes
glorieuses dans cette période de
l'après-guerre et en réalité on a fait
une révolution agricole c'était
magnifique on allait alimenter on allait
croître massivement on allait exporter
notre nos savoirs et puis on a développé
un système qui fait qu'aujourd'hui tu
manges du saumon dans ton Panini
quasiment tous les jours alors qu'avant
on mangeait du saumon à Noël tu vois et
pareil pour la viande et en fait le
problème c'est qu'on a développé un
système insoutenable et on s'est appuyé
sur quoi sur l'eau c'est à dire que tout
ça bien sûr sur le pétrole d'ailleurs
pour extraire du pétrole faut de l'eau
aussi et on a tendance
à voir ça fait longtemps que je regarde
la question claire je suis retombée sur
un rapport de l'Académie des sciences il
y a 15 ans qui disait si jamais le
l'évolution climatique et le scénario
s'avère tel que il semble enfin tel que
la trajectoire semble vouloir poser du
GIEC sont en train de nous présenter
c'est ça notamment en tous les cas donc
c'était à l'époque ben du coup ils nous
disent deux choses ils nous disent la
première chose qui va falloir réviser
parce que ce sera pas soutenable c'est
l'irrigation donc notre système agricole
et la deuxième chose c'est qu'à un
moment donné il y aura un problème avec
les centrales nucléaires et pourquoi il
y a un problème parce qu'en fait il faut
choisir entre le fait d'avoir des
circuits de refroidissement qui font
ressortir une eau beaucoup plus chaude
qui va atteindre le milieu récepteur et
toute la biodiversité la population
piscicole etc qui se trouve là et le
fait de soutenir le principe qu'on a des
vagues de chaleur et donc il va falloir
alimenter en énergie les clims il va
falloir choisir je pense qu'on va plutôt
choisir les clims que le poisson parce
que le poisson de toutes les façons ça
fait longtemps quand même que on s'y
intéresse pas trop la plupart de nos
cours d'eau ont des chutes drastiques de
toutes les populations piscicoles
personne ces 30 dernières années
c'est-à-dire que un moment donné il y a
même des des analyses qui ont été faites
pour essayer de comprendre je sais que
derrière EDF essaye d'évoluer ces
dernières années mais il y a encore 10
ans les lâchés de barrages étaient
vraiment fonction du cours de la bourse
c'est-à-dire qu'on se retrouvait avec
avec en fait tu as un poisson qui est là
tranquille dans son eau qui vient frayer
ses œufs etc et puis en fait compte tu
as une évolution du cours de la bourse
et de l'électricité et tu as un lâcher
de barrage massif et de cool le poisson
il comprend pas
mais c'est vrai et donc qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce poisson qui se croit libre
donc tu as ce problème c'est le poisson
tu as un autre problème pour ce pauvre
poisson c'est que derrière il s'est
mangé tous nos modes de vie donc en fait
bon au moins il est heureux parce qu'il
est rempli d'anxiolytique et
d'antidépresseurs donc ça c'est plutôt
cool
et surtout c'est ce que j'allais dire
c'est que derrière il y a une
féminisation des poissons dont on parle
pas peut-être parce que trop tabou chez
les plongeurs la féminisation du mérou
c'est un grand grand sujet
il faut comprendre ce qui se passe
d'ailleurs il y a pas que il y a pas que
les poissons il y a les loutres derrière
tout tout finalement la biodiversité et
tout tout ce qui la faune qui se trouve
au bord du cours d'eau vit un phénomène
de féminisation de pique la femme prend
la pilule dans les années 70
c'est-à-dire que massivement on a fait
manger à tout le monde des oestrogènes
et de la progestérone ça dépend des
types de pilules mais du coup tu te
retrouves avec avec des populations qui
s'effondre
croisé à ça bon alors maintenant ils
sont vaccinés en plus donc c'est plutôt
pas mal nos poissons ont leur place
sanitaires mais c'est des vraies
questions c'est à dire que je sais pas
si la protéine Spike se retrouve dans
les cours d'eau
ils ont un gros problème de féminisation
partout partout dans le monde partout un
moment donné tout ce qui passe dans nos
urines derrière que ce soit les
antibiotiques que ce soit les
antidépresseurs tout finit dans nos
cours d'eau si on croit que tout est
traité avant derrière on se tombe c'est
un peu comme quand on prend un déchet
qu'on le jette à la poubelle et qu'on
pense qu'il va être traité derrière ça
c'est le début du leur en fait et ben je
crois que c'est pareil en fait et
surtout quand on utilise les produits
phytosanitaires qui ont l'air magnifique
c'est à dire que la pub nous raconte à
quel point notre maison va relire on
aura absolument aucune bactérie aucun
virus ça va être magnifique sauf que
derrière ces produits là ils finissent
et puis derrière il y a écrit dangereux
avec avec des têtes de mort partout et
puis à la fin ça ça se retrouve chez le
poisson ce que je peux te couper
on va rentrer dans le dur du sujet tout
de suite parce que là parler des
poissons qui se féminisent on va dire
allez les gens ils sont là
au restaurant et à côté de ma table il y
avait quelqu'un qui prenait un filet de
Saint-Pierre alors je me disais le
poisson de nos profondes tu vois du
genre de petit détail bien il lève le
filet il se retrouve avec un bout de
plastique qui était déjà inséré dans
dans la chair du poisson et ça ça arrive
de plus souvent de plus en plus souvent
le petit le petit fil bleu vous avez
jamais trouvé ça dans vos poissons
[Musique]
plus tard revenons au sujet un peu plus
costaud
on va on va donner des données là on va
demander à notre communauté d'aller
chercher après pour bien se rendre
compte du du de l'esbroufe de nos
politiques donc là on est dans une
situation compliquée pas tellement
compliqué encore parce que le ciel n'est
pas encore tombé sur la sur notre tête
on a la guerre puis on a pas la guerre
avec le genre un pays de sauvage là on a
la guerre avec celui qui est assis sur
les réserves naturelles pratiquement du
monde
on a eu une pandémie on est toujours un
peu dans une pandémie
réchauffement climatique
réchauffement climatique ça c'est un
sacré poisson on a un problème avec un
système financier qui fait de la
cavalerie à longueur de temps qui est en
train de se faire rattraper par
l'addition du climat à pays et on se
retrouve avec des scientifiques qui font
de l'auto-censure
on discute avec des scientifiques qui
sont parfaitement au courant du taux de
vapeur d'eau
l'atmosphère et qui se refuse à dire que
l'augmentation de température plus la
concentration du taux d'humidité dans
l'air et l'étal un fameux rapport d'une
grande institution se refuse de créer
des paniques des
exodes massifs en Asie du Sud-Est
donc il se refuse de dire ça comment nos
politiques qui font pour s'informer ils
sont informés par des gens comme toi
ingénieurs qui bossent qui sont sur le
terrain qui qui gratte qui gratte où ils
sont baignés dans une petite un petit
climat de
les données ils contestent les données
comment ça se passe
alors déjà ta propre psychologie toi qui
est au courant que ça va super mal
comment toi tu fais pour gérer
personnellement ensuite on rentrera dans
la psychologie du politique et les
préconisations
donc comment toi tu réagis quand tu sais
que un taux d'humidité à X et une
température à Y qui va être sur beaucoup
de de continents
ultra peuplés sur ton bord de mer ainsi
de suite tu sais ce que ça fait ça fait
des mouvements migratoires ça crée des
guerres ça crée de la famille ça crée
des peurs et nous on est encore en
apesanteur je parle beaucoup je suis
infiniment désolé
envie de réagir à tout
déjà la première chose c'est essayer de
comprendre ce dont tu viens de parler
qui pour moi est un maillon essentiel et
j'arrive pas à comprendre pourquoi
personne n'en parle ça me paraît
inconcevable c'est que l'eau est le
premier gaz à effet de serre sur la
planète la vapeur d'eau et en fait non
c'est à dire que c'est grâce à ça alors
attends c'est grâce à l'eau qu'on
ressent pas la lune qu'on n'a pas un
gradient de 250 degrés entre le jour et
la nuit
c'est grâce à l'eau que derrière on a
une température moyenne sur la planète
qui derrière est vivable je te complète
c'est grâce à l'eau champ magnétique
au-delà de ça ce que je veux dire c'est
que l'eau c'est un gaz à effet de serre
et d'abord on peut se reposer la
question qu'est-ce qu'un gaz elle fait
de serre parce que souvent on nous
montre des schémas un gaz effet tir
c'est quoi c'est finalement tu as un
rayon incident lumineux qui va venir du
soleil qui va taper au sol qui va
rebondir et en rebondissant il va
rencontrer des molécules sur son chemin
soit il rencontre des molécules à deux
têtes j'ai envie de te dire qui vont
être éjectés finalement sur le chemin du
rayon soit il rencontre des molécules à
trois têtes et là tu as H2O tu as le C
O2 et toutes les molécules qui vont en
fin de compte être assez stables dans
l'atmosphère il va les faire vibrer et
donc il va les déstabiliser elles vont
se mettre à vibrer et quand elle vive
qu'est-ce qui se passe ça réchauffe et
de proche en proche elles vont
réchauffer toutes les molécules jusqu'à
arriver au sol et donc on va avoir des
MAS qui vont se réchauffer et donc le
premier déjà gaz à effet de serre donc
c'est l'eau c'est 95% des gaz à effet de
serre sur la planète
4,1% c'est le CO2 et le reste c'est le
méthane et tous les gaz fluoré etc qui
ont un effet extrêmement puissant
pourquoi est-ce qu'on en parle pas la
première raison c'est que on peut pas la
mesurer depuis un long temps dans les
calottes glaciaires tu peux mesurer le
CO2 parce que il a évolué et en
particulier de voir son évolution dans
l'atmosphère en allant chercher dans
l'histoire de la Terre à travers la
glace mais l'eau tu peux pas parce que
c'est déjà de l'eau glacière et qu'en
réalité tu les as pas ces informations
donc en fin de compte là où on n'a pas
d'informations et étant donné que l'eau
et le seul gaz à effet de serre qui
finit un moment donné par être instable
et par condensé nuclée et donc retomber
sous la forme de pluie
et bien on considère que il rentre pas
dans le système pourtant c'est 60 en
termes d'effets c'est 60 à 80% de
l'effet de serre qu'il y a la question
de l'eau alors j'ai cherché à comprendre
je me suis dit mais en fin de compte sur
la planète quelle est la quantité d'eau
atmosphérique
j'avais du mal à percevoir je savais que
derrière tu as
96,7% d'eau dans les océans tu as à peu
près 2% d'eau douce parce que du coup
dans les océans c'est les eaux salés
mais tu as 2% d'eau douce dans les
itelandsis donc arctique et Antarctique
dont 70% de l'eau douce est plutôt sur
l'Antarctique et puis tu as 1% dans les
nappes souterraines plutôt fossiles et
d'ailleurs c'est important à le
comprendre pour prendre notre fragilité
0,0012%
d'eau dans nos rivières et dans nos
fleuves c'est à dire que c'est la seule
lot directement disponible on a déjà
essayé d'aller chercher de l'eau en
remorquant dans les années 70 les
Émirats arabes ont essayé et se sont
vite confrontés à un problème de coût
derrière de transport et de problèmes
techniques donc ils ont arrêté mais en
fait c'est pas de l'eau disponible la
seule look disponible que l'on a déjà
elle est absolument infime sur terre et
quand tu regardes l'eau au niveau de de
toutes nos cette couronne en fait
atmosphérique qui compose notre
atmosphère principalement et ben en
réalité tu te rends compte que on a
l'équivalent de 1/7 de la mer Caspienne
c'est-à-dire rien
de mémoire je crois que c'est 14000 km
cube c'est à dire que en réalité la
quantité de vapeur d'eau elle est infime
sur la planète et sa modification elle
va avoir des conséquences dramatiques le
problème c'est que ça fait à peu près
une centaine d'années qu'on a compris
comment fonctionnait les forages on a
réussi à en faire de plus en plus
profondément donc on va taper dans
toutes les nappes fossiles dans le monde
et donc cette offensile qu'on va
récupérer Camille des fois des millions
d'années à se constituer tu regardes la
nappe du Sahara derrière il y a 6000 ans
finalement c'était complètement
luxuriant on n'était pas du tout sur un
désert et tu avais de l'eau qui
s'infiltrait donc tu as des nappes qui
sont gigantesques qui ont été récupérés
avec des milliards de mètres cubes d'eau
qui sont extraits ne serait-ce que par
la Libye tout le système finalement
agricole de toute cette zone là ne
fonctionne que sur des nappes fossiles
qui ne sont pas des nappes renouvelables
et donc en fin de compte cette taux
qu'on a été prélevé dans nos sous-sols
on l'a mis dans l'atmosphère
et quand elle est dans l'atmosphère
qu'est-ce qui se passe la seule chose
qui est assez ferme c'est soit être de
la vapeur d'eau soit finalement finir
par être conduit dans les réseaux
hydrographiques et finir dans les océans
donc quelles contribue à l'assurer
l'évasion du niveau de la mer d'après
certaines études je lis des chiffres de
l'ordre de 30 % à vérifier mais par
contre on augmente le pourcentage de
vapeur d'eau dans l'atmosphère donc si
on augmente le pourcentage de vapeur
d'eau celui qui qui est dans en inertie
celui qui peut pas bouger celui qui est
de toutes les façons constant en
permanence peu importe le cycle de l'eau
et ben on augmente l'effet de serre donc
on augmente la température et on
augmente l'évaporation et du coup on est
un espèce de enfin tu vois j'ai cette
image de hamster dans une cage qui va de
plus en plus vite et ça c'est le cycle
de l'eau en fait du coup l'eau condense
deux fois plus rapidement parce qu'il y
a beaucoup plus d'évaporation elle suit
des rivières atmosphériques et elle va
précipiter deux fois plus rapidement
c'est deux fois plus rapidement
ils ont fait ça il y a ces croyait à 5
ans non écoute j'essaye de lire toutes
les publications scientifiques qui
sortent elles elles semblent toutes
rejoindre les mêmes données la NASA
vient de montrer qu'on avait une
quantité de vapeur d'eau beaucoup plus
importante et c'est comme si on le
mettait de côté et la solution c'est que
de décarboner j'ai pas dit qu'il fallait
pas des carboner parce que effectivement
c'est un gaz à effet de serre et qu'il
est en inertie une fois que tu l'as émis
c'est trop tard derrière il est émis
pour un certain nombre d'années mais la
question de l'eau à côté moi je pose la
question est-ce que c'est pas le CO2 ce
que c'est pas l'arbre qui cache la forêt
redis-moi ça le CO2 est-ce que c'est pas
l'arbre qui cache la forêt qui se cache
derrière est-ce que le vrai problème
c'est pas juste le dérèglement du cycle
de l'eau majeur massif partout où tu as
deux responsables tu as nos villes et
nos campagnes dans nos modes agricoles
qui ont complètement détruit les sols
les sols ne sont plus capables
d'absorber l'eau est à nos villes sont
complètement imperméabilisé et seuls
c'est-à-dire que on a plus qu'un grand
cycle ou tu as de l'eau qui précipite
elle ruisselle elle peut absolument pas
pénétrer et elle finit deux fois plus
vite dans un cours d'eau ça augmente les
vitesses ça finit avec jutoire et
finalement tu recréer une boucle et je
me dis mais pourquoi on en parle pas
alors est-ce que je suis toute seule
dans sur ma planète derrière à essayer
de me dire de voir ça là je viens de
voir encore des tests de doctorat qui
viennent d'être soutenus en Suisse
on a une on a des chiffres parce qu'on a
calculé la part justement de vapeur
d'eau et on vous et c'est tous les
chiffres à l'échelle de la planète
semblent se rejoindre on augmente la
part de vapeur d'eau dans l'atmosphère
sur le bas de l'atmosphère et on semble
perdre de la vapeur d'eau en haute
atmosphère mais c'est terrible parce
qu'en réalité on est en train de perdre
notre atmosphère on en perd et elle se
condense elle se rétrécit et nous on est
là dedans et on est comme dans un espèce
de cocotte-minute et on le voit pas
venir parce qu'on a l'impression que ça
va pas nous concerner et donc
l'impression que le problème il est
indien actuellement que nous on a des
clims ouais et le problème c'est que tu
vois bien que toutes les vagues de
chaleur qu'il y a eu déjà ça génère deux
choses les canicules ça génère des feux
qui sont absolument pas maîtrisables par
l'homme donc redevenons peut-être un peu
humble
et deuxièmement ça génère effectivement
des organismes qui sont absolument pas
préparés et surtout des systèmes de
climatisation qui atteignent leurs
limites et ça personne n'en parle mais
derrière les 42 degrés à Paris dans tous
les hôpitaux de Paris tu avais plus de
clim quasiment et donc les gens
crevaient de chaleur mais on a oublié et
finalement continue ce modèle
productiviste et on continue à essayer
de trouver des solutions pour
terministes pour l'agriculture pôle
cours thermique sur
une espèce d'idéologie qui arrive c'est
à dire d'un seul coup on a trouvé une
nouvelle solution c'est magique ça y est
on a trouvé on a trouvé une solution
c'est génial on va tous arrêter
d'acheter des fringues et on va tous
décider de mettre des fringues de
seconde main derrière qui ont appartenu
à quelqu'un d'autre on va les racheter
dans des friperies et tout c'est la
solution ok super derrière on va
consommer moins de coton moins d'eau on
va éviter de sécher la mer d'Aral qui
est de façon de chez déjà à sécher mais
derrière le problème c'est que tu as une
gamine qui est là à qui tu dis ça d'un
côté et de l'autre côté tu lui mets des
pubs tous les 10 mètres derrière de tous
les géants de la mode qui se disent
maintenant green derrière
éco-responsable etc donc on est quand
même face à une sorte d'injonction
contradictoire permanente sur les gens
qu'on culpabilise en permanence je vois
les gens me disent mais tu sais j'ai
compris l'histoire climatique je trie
mes déchets mais tout simplement parce
que les gens ont été éduqués qu'à ça ils
savent pas que ça va les concerner ils
savent pas qu'une maison sur quatre elle
est dans une zone de retrait gonflement
d'argile et que ces sécheresses ces
accentuent le fait que ça coûte deux
fois plus cher pour le bâtiment une
sécheresse qu'une inondation les gens
n'ont pas compris qu'on a des nouvelles
formes d'inondation où ça concerne plus
simplement le principal cours d'eau ça
concerne la rue à partir du moment où il
y a une pente et à partir du moment où
le nuage a décidé de s'arrêter là mais
ça c'est le monde d'aujourd'hui et on a
des solutions c'est pas qu'on en a pas
on en a plein la solution locale
déjà commençons au moins par ces
solutions locales pour essayer de
protéger les populations on va prendre
sa protéger les populations je sais pas
s'ils connaissent bien le terme moi si
je pense qu'on peut essayer au moins de
faire en sorte qu'il y a pas de victimes
non mais
j'ai acté là
mais quand tu as une inondation je pense
qu'on peut essayer de leur expliquer que
là il faut évacuer que là il faut se
confiner il faut laisser passer l'eau on
peut au moins essayer de protéger
l'humain
les données sont là
tout est sur la table en fait on est les
champions du monde des Colocs et des
rapports on est incroyable
pathologique mais
du tout mais en fait la logique c'est
que on constate on constate on constate
et il se passe rien derrière il se passe
rien moi j'ai vu quelques années j'avais
des rapports j'avais relevé 380 types de
pesticides dans nos rivières en France
et attends une partie qui est interdite
en Europe aujourd'hui la semaine
dernière il y a un rapport qui est sorti
qui met en évidence le fait que
effectivement les pesticides ont atteint
tous les milieux le sol les nappes les
rivières
et après qu'est-ce qui se passe
on se retrouve avec un Pakistan pays
magnifique à 52 degrés on se retrouve
avec l'Inde pays magnifique à 48 degrés
pas de vent à rien nos médias nous
préviennent avec une jolie photo
d'enfants qui gazouille dans un lavoir
ils sont contents ils sont souriants
la nappe phréatique au Pakistan
elle touche par terre
la nappe phréatique
comme ça qu'est-ce qui se passe quand on
a un pays qui est surpeuplé sans eau qui
fait 50 degrés ils ont la bombe
nucléaire
ils font toc toc toc l'Himalaya ils font
toc toc toc la Chine toc toc toc là on
se bat pour l'eau la guerre de l'eau oui
non voyons voir
alors là tu poses plusieurs questions la
question de ces températures extrêmes
avec ses canicules ben on augmente le
flux évaporatoire on va faire chuter
drastiquement les rendements et
qu'est-ce que ça donne ça donne que
chaque pays pense à soi donc chacun pour
soi
mais en tous les cas qu'est-ce qui se
passe l'Inde décide de dire bah non en
fin de compte je comptais derrière vous
alimenter tous parce qu'effectivement
l'Ukraine n'était plus là mais en fin de
compte je vais d'abord garder mon blé
pour pour ma population et je crois que
je garde le blé pour éviter de se faire
trancher la tête
il prendrait des mesures proactives pour
ça mais nos pays quand ils refusent
d'exporter c'est pour nous c'est pour
nous protéger l'État les ta maman l'état
Pat
mais là en fait ils exportent pas pour
éviter que les gens posent des questions
comment on en est arrivé là désolé pour
cet aparté
peut-être en tous les cas je pense que à
partir du moment où chaque pays va se
retrouver dans une situation de crise
chacun va penser à soi et nous on a
absolument pas intégré le fait que notre
assiette alimentaire elle vient du
supermarché et si elle vient du
supermarché c'est qu'il y a de l'eau
caché derrière
chaque kilo calories d'eau tu as un
litre d'eau c'est-à-dire que en moyenne
on a à peu près trois quatre millilitres
d'eau caché dans notre assiette déjà
juste notre assiette tu rajoutes nos
habits tu rajoutes nos véhicules tout ce
que l'on consomme derrière qui utilise
de l'eau dans tous les process tu
augmentes la part carnée bah tu te
retrouves avec 5 à 7 ml d'eau mais cette
eau tant qu'elle vient d'ailleurs
puisque nous on consomme à la limite 150
litres d'eau par jour qu'on va aller
prélever dans la nappe à côté de chez
nous tu vois tu as à peu près 62% de
l'eau des Français
et le reste vient des milieux
superficiels mais on va piocher dans nos
nappes mais ça c'est pour nous c'est
pour nous laver c'est pour le quotidien
etc sauf qu'en fait on a oublié un truc
c'est que l'eau c'est tout faire pour
moi j'appelle ça pour moi l'eau c'est au
potentiel c'est-à-dire que c'est celle
qui sait tellement tout faire elle s'est
réchauffée elle s'est refroidi elle
s'est elle sait se condensée elle peut
être dans tous les états et donc en fait
on l'utilise dans tous les systèmes
industriels on l'utilise à tous les
niveaux on utilise pour notre
alimentation on l'utilise pour l'énergie
on l'utilise pour l'industrie donc un
monde sans eau derrière c'est un monde
qui ne peut plus fonctionner sur ce mode
là alors tu vas me dire mais attends il
y a 71% de planètes qui recouvert des
océans
donc
en fin de compte on a calé la chercher
là l'eau tu vois c'est comme on m'a dit
on m'a dit un truc que je trouvais
génial et quelqu'un qui m'a dit mais
attends pourquoi on se prend la tête
avec les déchets nucléaires on a qu'à
les envoyer dans l'espace c'est à peu
près pareil je trouve ça assez
intéressant
je trouve ça assez intéressant parce que
je me dis mais en fin de compte on a
l'impression que on a une planète bleue
c'est le cas on a de l'eau on a des
dernières études scientifiques montrent
que on aurait eu de l'eau depuis depuis
la naissance même de la terre elle a
même pas été il a même pas eu un apport
tardif des comètes elle était déjà
présente on a l'équivalent de deux fois
nos océans dans le manteau
supérieur inférieur donc de l'eau on en
a alors qu'est-ce qui se passe pourquoi
derrière on va se plaindre on a qu'à
désalinisé l'eau de mer et le problème
c'est que tu te confrontes à un problème
majeur c'est que ben oui mais pour
désaminer il faut de l'énergie alors tu
regardes le modèle de Malte c'est
intéressant depuis des années 80
ils n'ont pas eu le choix que de
déstabiliser parce qu'ils avaient pas
d'eau pour leur population donc ils ont
investi dans cette visite de dessalement
massive et ils allaient chercher en fin
de compte leur énergie ou avec le
pétrole en Libye
donc ça fonctionnait jusqu'à un certain
temps sauf qu'à un moment donné il faut
trouver d'autres modes d'alimentation
énergétique et là c'est plus compliqué
donc dès que tu as un système qui est
fondé sur un autre tu as une
interdépendance si tu as un système qui
chute à l'autre qui chute quand tu me
demandais quels sont les effets domino
c'est ça et je crois que si on regarde
tu parlais du Pakistan et de l'Inde on a
des rendements agricoles qui chutent
partout et donc en réalité tu as encore
les salades vertes chez les Américains
qui sont fournis par la Californie qui
s'appuie sur les nappes fossiles tant
qu'il y en a donc on continue tant qu'il
y en a à pomper on sait très bien qu'on
va assécher la nappe mais on y va comme
si c'était du pétrole et en continu on
continue on continue on laisse pas le
temps au nappes de ce de se refaire et
on respecte plus rien mais le problème
c'est que j'ai beau regardé partout je
tourne la planisphère j'essaie de
regarder toutes les sécheresses partout
tu en as partout des sécheresses
c'est-à-dire que c'est le principal
phénomène qui se passe sur la terre
actuellement
ce sont des sécheresses des vagues de
chaleur des canicules qui se confrontent
à des airs très froids en ce moment tu
as un air très froid bloqué sur les
Balkans qui vont jusqu'à la Russie mais
par contre derrière tu as un nouveau
dôme de chaleur qui est en train
d'arriver sur l'Europe donc en fin de
compte tu as des confrontations de masse
d'air toujours plus tendus mais à chaque
fois que tu as un dôme de chaleur tu as
un phénomène évaporatoires est à une
chute drastique de l'aliment du
potentiel alimentaire et donc la Chine
dans les années 80 a subi une sécheresse
historique elle a prévu le coup elle a
acheté les céréales sur les marchés
mondiaux en se disant bah en prévision
finalement d'une pénurie et d'une famine
je vais prévoir le coup et donc la
population s'en est même pas rendu
compte et ça c'est possible quand tu
peux aller chercher ton blé ailleurs
mais quand tu as plus de blé là là on va
pas compter sur la Russie l'Ukraine ça
semble compliqué l'un de nous a dit non
je sais pas trop où on va aller la
chercher enfin compte et donc pour
alimenter quoi c'est aussi la question
qu'on doit se poser cette agriculture là
qu'on importe et comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait essayer de réfléchir au moins à
petit échelle si un système qui
s'effondre à la manière dont on va être
résignant sur le plan alimentaire et
c'est une question personne se pose j'ai
lu des chiffres de rapport faut les
vérifier parce que derrière c'est
quelque chose que je creuse donc si tu
as des auditeurs moi je pense qu'il faut
aller essayer de chercher somme d'infos
j'entendais des chips de l'ordre de 2%.
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
l'agriculture française nourrit 2% des
Français
[Musique]
une recherche qui avait été faite
dernièrement j'ai trouvé ce chiffre
assez dingue parce que
nos fruits nos légumes et ça déjà 70%
des terres en Europe alimentent les
bovins donc déjà tu en enlèves déjà une
grande partie et nos voitures et une
partie des biocarburants qui est aussi
une vraie question est-ce qu'on laisse
la place pour alimenter en biocarburant
ou est-ce qu'on laisse la place pour
nous pour manger c'est des questions de
choses posées
et donc en fait on se retrouve avec un
système qui arrive à bout de course quoi
tu vois donc et la seule chose qui nous
reste comme possibilité c'est
transformer nos territoires transformer
nos terres recréer les cycles de loi
petit échelle faire de l'agroforesterie
ça paraît très utopique mais en fin de
compte c'est hyper bien pensé il faut
rajouter des haies rajouter de l'ombre
parce que l'ombre ça sert à quelque
chose
le système financier mondial qui est
basé sur on court on court on court on
fait du profit on fait du profit puis
les pertes c'est pour vous ok
notre système financier qui est basé sur
une consommation exponentielle
si on arrête ce système là
l'inertie
le côté inextriqueable intriquée du
système financier qui est censé être le
vecteur pour alimenter les industries
pour financer les industries c'est
pipeau Pipou
quand on se retrouve avec ce système à
bout de souffle au bord du gouffre et
collation lui rajoute des guerres des
sécheresses désinondations et des
petites choses comme ça
il va jamais s'adapter on a on a une
classe politique
occidentale je parle pas que française
ils sont à l'ouest ils sculptent de la
fumée il brasse de l'air chaud
par rapport au réel défis quand on
entend dire que les gens dans l'Asie du
Sud-Est au Pakistan en Inde il subissent
des vagues de chaleur
mortels si son pas sous la clim en
milieu concentré et tempérée et
monitory il claque dans la rue
les ouvriers maintenant sont obligés de
dormir dehors pour éviter
les politiques qui vont jamais s'adapter
ils vont nier jusqu'au bout ils vont
essayer jusqu'au bout du dire oui les
solutions comprenez madame michute ou
bien se passer on y travaille on
justifie la concertation de la
gouvernance c'est ça donc là quand on se
retrouve avec un code de la route qui
est pas respecté
d'accord l'État le notre politique sont
bien le truc
sous des prétextes de on va faire la
sécurité routière on va prendre un peu
de pognon mais la sécurité routière ça
fonctionne aussi le radar le gendarme
satisfaite est-ce qu'il va falloir
passer par des mesures coercitives
je pense qu'on a pas le choix on a on
est à l'aube d'une nouvelle forme de
révolution
je crois qu'effectivement tu as raison
on arrive dans un dans un système qui
est complètement en
une inertie totale c'est à la fois il y
a du bon il y a des choses terribles
c'est que tu parlais des réunionites je
crois que ça va plus loin c'est qu'on a
des politiques qui sont longs qui sont
lourdes qui sont complexes qui mettent
du temps et je crois que ça désespère
même ceux qui sont dans le système voilà
tous les systèmes sont en train de se
rendre compte qu'il faudrait qu'il bouge
moi je parle avec des banquiers je leur
donne un peu de trois chiffres et moi
peut-être que je vais en parler à ma
direction parce qu'effectivement ça va
peut-être s'intéresser ça fait mais à la
fois tu te rends compte que il s'intègre
pas du tout dans leur prêt immobilier le
fait que la baraque elle sera fait sous
l'eau dans 20 ans on continue un système
on continue un système et on se met des
œillères et je crois qu'effectivement
les assureurs commencent à comprendre
qu'il faudrait peut-être qu'ils aient un
rôle de préventeur mais de là à changer
système ça demande quand même beaucoup
parce que derrière c'est des c'est des
mindset c'est des manières de penser qui
ont été construites sur des décennies et
d'un seul coup tu leur dis il faut
changer il faut devenir agile derrière
pas il faut se transformer on va changer
de métier on va derrière en plus tu les
accompagnes pas donc bon moi j'ai quand
même j'essaie tu me demandais quel était
mon état j'essaye d'être resté tout le
temps positif pourquoi
non mais c'est vrai j'ai une fois j'ai
vraiment j'ai été désespérée c'est quand
j'ai vu arriver sur les images
satellites le dôme de chaleur avant
couvert et quand j'ai vu little cramer
en trois heures là je suivais les images
satellites et là j'ai eu un coup je me
suis dit mais en fait personne n'a
compris quoi la température moyenne
là-bas c'est 18-20 degrés à cette
période de l'année normalement on est
monté à 49 degrés 7 mais en fait on n'a
pas compris on n'a pas compris ce qui
arrive devant nous
et que ça va nous concerner nous aussi
c'est pas juste parce que Vancouver
parce que quand tu regardes en fait il y
avait un projet de pipeline pour
alimenter depuis le nord et du Canada le
sud et la Californie pour que la
Californie continue à produire son
agriculture intensive et en réalité on a
tout coupé parce qu'il y avait autant de
sécheresse au Nord qu'au Sud et donc
comme l'hémisphère Nord se réchauffe
trois fois plus vite que le reste de la
planète ben derrière ça donne des choses
qu'on avait vraiment pas vu venir donc
là j'ai vraiment je me suis dit waouh ok
où est-ce qu'on va c'est compliqué
d'avoir les données d'avoir les chiffres
en tête de voir tout ça et à la fois le
reste du temps j'essaye de me dire bah
écoute je donne tout ce que j'ai ça fait
20 ans je suis libre
je suis autonome au pire comme dirait
candide je construirai mon propre jardin
et derrière je cultive vraiment jardin
et j'essaierai de d'être le plus
autonome possible je veux pas paraître
tu vois dans cette lotion d'effondrement
parce que j'espère j'espère j'espère
qu'à un moment donné il y aura un réveil
je crois qu'il y a un réveil quand même
de beaucoup de gens beaucoup de gens
dans les populations il y a de plus en
plus de gens qui qui se sentent à la
fois impuissant mais qui ont envie de
faire des choses et je crois qu'en fin
de compte on doit tous essayer à son
échelle de se dire qu'est-ce que je peux
faire et au moins le faire et je me dis
si jamais j'ai des gamins aussi et
derrière je les vois grandir et je me
dis si jamais j'y arrive pas au moins
j'aurais tout fait pour j'aurais essayé
de donner tout ce que j'ai dans la vie
j'essaye en tous les cas tu vois j'ai
créé un centre appliqué de recherche
toute seule sans financement sans rien
j'ai essayé de voir ce qu'on pouvait
aller comme on pouvait aider les vides
c'est pas spécialement simple tous les
jours
j'ai créé une asso pour former les
enfants dans les écoles parce que je
suis convaincue que ça passe par là
plus de 100000 maintenant
Instagram
éducation je l'ai créé en même temps
j'ai voulu dire on peut créer un système
privé un centre de recherche privé pour
travailler sur l'adaptation et payer cet
TVA et ses impôts etc et en même temps
créer un système but de philanthropique
qui va juste servir à à alimenter les
savoirs à aider les consciences des
jeunes à se transformer et je les fais
sans rien attendre sans jamais
attendre enfin voilà rien mais par
contre ça marche et les gamins sont
émerveillés et en fait ils veulent plus
moi j'ai commencé les premières
animations j'ai créé avec des équipes
pédagogiques les premiers les premières
journées de sensibilisation et les
gamins voulaient plus plus aller à la
récré quoi et en fait pour moi je gagne
quelque chose parce que je me disais
mais c'est merveilleux en fin de compte
ça sert à quelque chose après tu vois
j'ai continué j'ai essayé d'enseigner
partout j'enseignais dans l'école
d'Inger à la fac j'ai créé puis là
maintenant je le fais dans les médias
bah tant mieux tant mieux j'essaye
peut-être certains m'écoutent d'autres
pas et puis peu importe je continue et
je me dis peut-être qu'on peut tous à
son échelle si on a ce sentiment d'avoir
un bien commun et d'être on a besoin à
un moment donné de cet altruisme on a
besoin de de voir les choses en plus
grand que sur soi-même ça veut pas dire
que je pense pas mon bien-être à mon
confort etc mais ça veut dire que
j'essaye au moins de faire ma part je ça
fait 35 ans que ça fait 35 ans que je
mange bio je mange que des fruits et
légumes que je transforme moi-même
derrière déjà ma part tu vois j'utilise
pas du plastique j'utilise pas de
produits transformés je mange pas de
viande derrière c'est ma part je demande
rien à personne moi je crée aucun modèle
je considère que c'est un modèle qui est
plus soutenable tu vois j'achète que
quelques fringues par an et encore bah
voilà moi ça me suffit en fait ça me
suivit parce que je suis heureuse et
donc tu me demandais comment je suis bah
je suis super bien tous les jours parce
que derrière j'ai des gosses qui sont
heureux qui qui sourit tous les jours et
qui voilà et qui me donne beaucoup
d'amour et en fin de compte ça me rend
heureuse ça me donne encore plus envie
de continuer puis en plus ils sont fiers
de moi ils ont dit 15 18 et 24
manger avec le réchauffement climatique
tu leur as dit
ils le savent mais je le dis sous un
mode de dérision parce que derrière je
veux pas les heurter et je me rends
compte que à chaque fois tu vois
beaucoup évolu notamment dans la période
d'adolescence certains changent moi je
vois mon plus grand un moment donné il
me regardait en mode tu me fais chier
avec ton bio ton truc vegan ton seitan
et ton tofuge j'en peux plus tu vois je
comprends je comprends parce qu'à un
moment donné j'ai pas imposé ça et en
fait
et en fait le grand et ben je me suis
rendu compte que il s'est mis à suivre
mon chemin et que finalement il mange
aujourd'hui
vegan comme moi végétarien et que
derrière il a compris mais il lui a fait
j'ai jamais forcé j'ai jamais cherché un
posé un système tu as envie de manger ça
manger j'ai pas envie de dire non je
suis contre ce modèle parce que ça sert
à rien sur un gamin ça sert à rien il
est il est dans la dans sa cour d'école
derrière il est entouré d'un système qui
semble être le système pour être à la
hauteur pour se sentir aimé des autres
pour derrière donc c'est qu'un système
émotionnel sur lequel bosse toutes nos
pubs moi je suis passionnée par le
neuromarketing et par les notes mais
quand tu comprends à quel point on a
manipulé nos cerveaux à quel point on
manipule nos consciences en permanence
en nous montrant un super gel douche
avec des magnifiques perles comme ça qui
viennent de Tahiti et qui derrière et tu
vois et tu vois en même temps un dauphin
qui saut derrière toi et c'est
merveilleux et que tu comprends que
c'est biplastique a fini sa mère et
finalement finissent par intoxiquer
toute la chaîne alimentaire bien sûr que
derrière j'essaye de faire attention à
mon échelle à mon échelle je me dis tout
ce que je prône je le prône de manière à
essayer d'être respectueuse de ce que
j'ai autour de moi c'est la seule chose
que je peux transmettre c'est mes
valeurs je peux peut-être pas donner un
monde plus durable mais au moins je peux
donner ce que je suis moi tu vois
en terme de temps
mais si je les pose tout à la suite là
c'est bon on va tous se mettre une corde
c'est terminé
on a on a un système financier tu
parlais des banquiers les banquiers sont
venus de voir en disant voilà qu'est-ce
qui se passe il se doute bien en fait
qu'il y a certains produits financiers
qui vont être détestés par les gens il y
a certaines marques qui savent qui vont
être détestés que les gens vont vouloir
se venger le fait qu'on les ait abreuver
de
les chevelure qui va bien la vie de
plastique le vroum broum qui va bien et
tout ça il est les gens vont aller
demander des des réponses certains
banquiers disent attention toi ta
société avec des tester les gens vont se
fâcher contre toi donc commence à te
changer
un taux vibratoire autour de Total que
derrière on est presque en train de
faire du yoga quand on achète total
énergie on passera plus chez nous par
rapport
Patrick
revenons à cette histoire de banquiers
il avait l'air inquiet pas inquiet il
voulait savoir comment ça allait être je
pense que je l'ai heurté en tant que
citoyen tu vois et c'est là je pense
qu'on peut encore agir c'est que ce
niveau de conscience il arrive à partir
du moment où tu comprends que ça va te
concerner tant que tu es dans ton
confort cette concerne pas quand tu
commences à comprendre tu es un citoyen
que tu es un parent et peint derrière je
trouve qu'en tous les cas il y a une
prise de conscience je peux pas dire que
derrière un changement des comportements
je pense que tu me le disais j'essaie
d'y réfléchir je pense qu'on doit être
coercitif on n'a pas le choix il faut
qu'on arrête la partie d'au moins 90% de
la population française aujourd'hui
j'essaye d'aller dans tout resto
quasiment impossible de manger un truc
sans viande c'est vraiment très
compliqué c'est accroît la bannière
derrière à chaque fois que je voyage
c'est très compliqué tu manges que de la
merde partout et en fait on alimente un
système pourri partout tu vas dans les
duty free dans les derrière quand tu
arrives dans les dans les parfumeries
t'as pas un produit qui a été construit
sans dioxyde de titane qui est
cancérigère reconnu qui devait être
interdit en Europe
moi ça me fait penser à l'époque de
Marie Curie qui derrière avait inventé
la radioactivité et on avait créé une
crème radioactive et toutes les femmes
se l'arrachaient
sur le visage et toutes les femmes se
sont mis des crèmes radioactives et puis
en l'espace de quelques semaines elles
sont mortes dans la fausse souffrance de
cette histoire moi elle me marque parce
que derrière je me dis mais enfin de
compte personne se rend compte que on
mange je vais être un peu plus du coup
je vais sortir de mon cas très
scientifique mais je vais revenir sur
juste moi en fait on mange que de la
merde derrière on toutes nos crèmes
hydratantes sont remplies de plastique
c'est ce qui permet de nous hydrater
sont remplis de produits cancérigènes on
le sait on change pas on met du
marketing dessus tu as j'ai trouvé une
seule marque qui n'a pas de maquillage
sans produit
sans produit reconnu comme cancérigène
en tous les cas nocifs mais qu'est-ce
que tu veux faire tu veux faire sauter
tout le système il faudrait demain
et donc en fait si tu veux je trouve
qu'on est dans un espèce de système où
tout le marketing est émotionnel tout
est basé sur tes émotions moi ça
m'intéresse beaucoup d'essayer de
comprendre quels sont les émotions des
gens tu vois je suis peut-être je suis
peut-être de l'hydrologie humaine
quelqu'un qui m'a dit ça j'ai trouvé ça
intéressant parce que effectivement j'ai
fait un doctorat en hydrologie mais
c'est ça ouais j'ai commencé par la
géologie
en fait d'aller taper du caillou
derrière au moins ça te permet de savoir
à quoi tu as à faire et quand tu vois un
territoire tu sais de quoi tu parles moi
j'ai toujours été passionné par ça je me
suis dit quand j'étais gamine je voyais
des rivières je marchais pendant des
heures je voyais des roches partout je
comprenais rien et à l'époque j'étais
fan Darwin Tazieff et je me suis dit un
jour j'essaierai de comprendre et donc
effectivement j'ai commencé par les
sciences de la terre tu vois c'est hyper
large en fait ça comprend la géophysique
donc la télé détection spatiale tu
comprends les images satellites tu
essayes de de tu comprends vraiment des
choses assez la je l'ai mis ça va
déminéraux derrière à la formation de
notaire et à chaque fois que j'arrive
dans un lieu je comprends comment il
s'est formé je comprends derrière si on
est sur des roches métamorphiques si on
est plutôt sur des calcaires je sais que
là il y avait un ancien océan et donc je
vais aller essayer de comprendre en fait
ce territoire et puis après j'ai basculé
un jour j'ai découvert l'hydrogéologie
alors j'ai trouvé ça fantastique c'est
l'étude de nos nappes souterraines et de
toutes nos milieux souterrains qui
reçoivent de l'eau alors là j'ai trouvé
ça extraordinaire et puis j'ai été un
peu plus loin et je me suis
je fais un débat à une greffe en
c'est de l'hydrologie en fait c'est à
dire que c'est vraiment des sciences de
l'eau dans l'environnement continental
c'est-à-dire que c'est les lots qui est
au dessus c'est pas l'eau qui est
au-dessous et d'ailleurs j'ai jamais
compris pourquoi on avait les
hydrogéologues d'un côté les hydrologues
de l'autre moi j'ai l'impression d'être
un peu les deux parce que je me suis
formé sur les deux et surtout l'eau elle
passe dessous elle vient dessus et c'est
là où j'ai découvert surtout qu'en fin
de compte le système scientifique était
clos et moi je peux pas avoir des
barrières donc je me balade donc en fait
j'ai fini par faire mon doctorat je l'ai
commencé en hydrologie et je l'ai fini
par le valider en psychosociologie des
organisations et en hydrologie grand
désespoir non directeur de thèse qui me
disait mais scientifique qu'est-ce que
tu fais à lire des bouquins de psycho
bah moi je pense que ça me passionne
parce que si tu as pas la clé de
l'humain tu passes complètement à côté
de d'une clé de lecture de ce qu'on peut
faire et donc pour revenir sur ce que je
te disais ce marketing émotionnel fait
que on a joué dans un sens et peut-être
qu'on peut l'utiliser pour jouer dans
l'autre sens faire du marketing par
exemple pour rendre la viande has been
pour transformer le système
donc votez avec le porte-monnaie c'est
ça ok je pense que c'est la solution
donc ce grand jour de prise de
conscience ou tout le monde aura la main
sur le cœur on se fera des bisous il y
aura plus de guerre sur terre avec tout
le monde mangera sa fin tu auras plus de
gens qui dorment dans la rue que les
femmes s'arrêteront de se faire tabasser
que il y aura plus de burqa partout et
bon ce jour-là n'arrivera pas donc il
m'a ça sert à rien moi je te pose une
question en tant que hydrogéologue
on fait comment pour s'organiser quand
il y a plus de flotte que les gens se
tapent sur la gueule que le pouvoir
politique est complètement dépassé que
les policiers payaient 4000 balles pour
qu'ils continuent de taper sur les
manifestants bah ils comprennent que
aussi ils vont être pris dans le dans le
problème tu ferais quoi dans ces cas-là
genre grosse canicule imagine à Paris il
s'approche banlieue là tu commences à
avoir des des problèmes
d'approvisionnement et les gens
commencent à se taper dessus tu fais
quoi
tu arrives tu fais
un coup de baguette magique mais je vais
essayer
la première chose que je ferais c'est
peut-être de m'appuyer sur un arbre
peut-être que il y a pas mieux qu'un
arbre derrière pour et de de je sais pas
si tu l'as lu j'ai relu il y a pas
longtemps le bouquin de vionnaud l'homme
qui plante et des arbres je trouve que
c'était tellement merveilleux mais en
fait on peut tellement faire on peut
tellement planter de graines à notre
échelle que je me dis que effectivement
j'essaierai d'avoir sans doute un jardin
ou un potager pour moto alimenter au
maximum
de faire des réserves de faire des
concerts derrière de d'essayer de
m'entourer de zones
arboricole enfin voilà d'essayer de
mettre du végétal partout pour essayer
de recréer des petits cycles de l'eau
aujourd'hui tu as à l'échelle
individuelle on est capable d'avoir des
sortes de fontaines derrière où tu
puisses l'eau atmosphérique peut-être
que c'est une solution demain pour que
les gens aient de l'eau
c'est une vraie question en tous les cas
il y a des innovations qui sont en train
d'arriver et qui sont intéressantes tu
vois il y a des innovations tu peux
avoir ton toit qui va être pas en blanc
bah tu vas gagner 10 degrés sur ta
baraque et tu vas peut-être pas finir
dans un sauna toute ta nuit je pense
qu'il y a il y a des choses à mettre en
place c'est sûr que à l'échelle
individuelle tu me poses la question je
pense que je peux peut-être réussir à
trouver pas mal de solutions j'étais sur
le terrain ces deux dernières semaines
et j'ai été voir notamment des zones qui
ont été particulièrement touchées par
les sécheresses et à quelques kilomètres
de là là on a conservé les forêts là on
a conservé les sols là on n'a pas
labouré là on a laissé de la matière
organique la nappe elle était juste là
en fait derrière le milieu conserve tout
et juste à quelques kilomètres de là tu
as une sécheresse gigantesque donc en
fait j'essaierai à mon échelle de
reconstruire un système avec de avec de
la cohérence avec de la conscience au
moins ma petite échelle
voilà ce que j'ai s’arrête de faire mais
je sais que derrière je suis pas dans le
monde des poupées Barbie et derrière de
maman d'utopique mais en tous les cas
j'essaierai de réfléchir à un système en
le plus autonome possible pour essayer
d'être le plus résilient possible et je
garderai le sourire même si derrière il
y a tout qui s'effondre parce que je
crois que c'est la seule chose qui nous
reste en fait
la poudre aussi mais c'est un autre
problème de qui n'est pas d'hydrologue
on a doute phénomène on voulait en
parler avec toi quand on voit
Bangkok se casser la gueule parce qu'il
pompe leur natte frétille qu'est-ce qui
se passe quand la nappe phréatique elle
peut pas se reconstruire on change de
pays
alors j'aurais tendance à te dire oui et
que toutes les études montrent des
migrations massives à prévoir j'ai un
peu l'impression tous les cas de ce que
je vois dans le monde que les gens sont
tellement sous le choc de ce qu'ils
voient que tu sais que c'est un peu
comme l'histoire de la souris tu sais
qui a été testé avec son cerveau
reptilien et qui soit attaque soit fuis
soit bouge pas tu vois tu as trois
comportements dans au niveau du bulbe
brachidien dans le cerveau reptilien
chez la souris mais chez nous aussi
tu en as trois et en fait je crois que
de ce que je vois les comportements
humains que je vois actuellement c'est
plutôt qu'on bouge pas on est comme ça
exactement en fait on au début j'ai
essayé de commencer à alerter il y a
trois quatre ans on ira attendez on a
atteint une température humide qui
mélange l'humidité atmosphérique avec la
température corporelle qui fait que
l'humain ne peut pas tenir plus de trois
heures parce que l'urée à un moment
donné ne peut plus évacuer et donc le
système un plotent de l'intérieur et
puis ça c'était une je crois que c'était
à 3-4 ans et puis il y a une autre
publication qui est sortie on l'a trouvé
dans 10 points sur terre et puis au fur
et à mesure c'est quelque chose qui
évolue donc on sait très bien que c'est
quelque chose qu'on va vivre de plus en
plus c'est à dire que derrière les 50
degrés qu'on a actuellement en Inde
c'est un gap mais on aura sans doute
d'ici
7-8 ans 50 degrés en France parce qu'on
a atteint 46 degrés finalement c'est à 4
degrés près tu vois c'est quand même
quelque chose qui est qui est pas très
loin
exactement au sol tu es plutôt dans les
62°c et donc
c'est quelque chose qu'on va vivre donc
écoute j'espère
que peut-être si des politiques nous
écoutent si des gens qui parlent aux
politiques nous écoutent si des gens qui
ont des pouvoirs à l'échelle
territoriale nous écoutent que il va y
avoir une vraie grande prise de
conscience sur le fait que le maïs pas
possible en fait déjà faut être clair
faut le dire il faut sortir de toutes
les logiques de lobby et des dizaines de
milliers de lobbies qu'on a et qui se
cache derrière la Commission européenne
nos politiques
et je crois que non je crois qu'il faut
dire en fait et qui a un moment donné
faut juste être factuel réel clair et
dire qu'à mon avis il y a des systèmes
qu'on peut plus conserver mais par
contre tu peux prendre cette agriculteur
qui lui pour le coup tu me parlais de
femmes sandwich lui il est pris en
sandwich il est pris en sandwich par des
agro industriels qui finalement le force
à faire des choses que lui n'aurait
jamais fait et lui il suit finalement un
système qui le nourrit enfin qui essaye
en tous les cas parce qu'il nourrit même
pas c'est même pas rentable la plupart
du temps et en réalité pourquoi est-ce
qu'on demanderait pas assez sachant de
la terre qui sont capables d'aller sur
le terrain parce que tous les citadins
c'est pas vraiment tout il y en a plein
qui se lancent dans la grand foresterie
mais quand même tout le monde n'est pas
capable d'aller dans un champ tous les
jours et ben pourquoi on lui demanderait
pas de que justement devenir quelqu'un
qui va protéger le fait de capter le
carbone tant qu'à faire on capte l'eau
aussi parce que quand tu s’éclasses le
carbone tu sais qu'elle se reloit aussi
donc ça résoudrait pas mal de problèmes
et en fait
pourquoi on lui donnerait pas la fameuse
tac enfin tu vois les crédits carbone
que derrière on utilise pour changer
notre chaudière et bah pourquoi on lui
fournirait pas justement le fait que lui
en fonction du nombre de mètres carrés
qui va protéger où il va laisser la
végétation reprendre laisser du des
prairies refaire renaître des forêts
réaméliorer la qualité de l'eau
transformer nos matières et nos
ressources primaires à en augmentant la
par qualitative qui derrière la
quantitative et ben derrière on devrait
financer ce système là en s'appuyant sur
ces gens-là mais ça veut dire qu'il faut
revoir notre modèle je te casserais
j'ai vu un agriculteur vice président de
la FN ça m'a suffit pour comprendre que
on était encore très très loin derrière
du modal idéal
mais vous rendez pas compte le trou de
rendement que ça va créer on va avoir
des émeutes dans les rues on va avoir un
effet domino sur tous les produits
financiers qu'on a archiitrisé sur les
matières premières alimentaires ce trou
de rendement il pourra plus payer les
retraites de nos fonctionnaires mais
vous êtes ça va pas la tête pourquoi
vous voulez faire ça vous êtes
dangereuse en fait un trou dans les un
trou de rendement regardez on a
l'Ukraine on a l'Ukraine donc c'est quoi
c'est 20% du mal du marché mondial de de
matière première alimentaire le blé oh
là là on va voir des famines partout bon
ça va être chez sauvages en priorité il
se compare du robinet on s'en fout un
peu c'est loin
c'est ce qui va se passer
écoute oui et non j'espère que tu vois
des médias comme le tien et puis je
pense que je vois de plus en plus de
prise de conscience notamment dans les
journalistes réels sincères de nom de
plus en plus vraiment je le vois d'année
en année non vraiment je le je le
constate régulièrement je crois que
en fait
ben peut-être que on peut préconiser
proposer un nouveau modèle le forcer
je sais pas comment je sais pas où je
j'espère que derrière notre pouvoir des
lecteurs notre pouvoir derrière à
travers notre porte-monnaie pourraient
peut-être contribuer
mais j'ai envie de croire que c'est
possible tu vois parce que derrière si
c'est pas possible si t'as pas ce désir
de réussir et d'avancer
si t'as pas un pourquoi tu te lèves pas
le matin et en fait moi j'ai envie de me
lever le matin avec un pourquoi et de me
dire que c'est possible
non dis-moi un film avec des zombies
malades qui voulaient un petit peu
manger tout le monde non la théorie du
10ème c'est quand tu as 10 personnes qui
pensent dans le même sens il faut qu'il
y en ait un qui pense à l'inverse de
tous les autres juste on sait jamais si
neufs qui étaient avec toi ils sont
plantés au moins tu as une solution de
backup nous on va essayer de faire le
dixième homme aujourd'hui on a des
politiques qui sont qui sont mais
dépassées dans une catatonie
émotionnelle dramatique ils sont dans
une cavalerie de voter pour moi c'est
ira mieux demain je suis l'homme
providentiel l'homme du pouvoir d'achat
il va rien se passer il va rien se
passer c'est un système qui est fait
pour faire perdurer le ronron quotidien
jusqu'au dernier moment ils vont être
dans la dans le déni et dans la négation
tu parlais d'études psychologique de sur
le neuromarketing institut la même chose
chez les politiques est-ce que tu te
rends compte tu vas dire à ces gens-là
bon maintenant le forage pour la nappe
phréatique pour alimenter les champs de
colza pour faire baisser ta taxe carbone
de faire baisser baisser 10 centimes le
prix du gasoil pour éviter qu'il est
manifestations avant les élections
présidentielles
ils en sont là écoute je pense à la fois
que tu as raison et à la fois j'aimerais
te donner tort donc en fait je me dis
moi je continue à essayer je suis libre
j'ai mon
j'ai récupéré mon pouvoir depuis bien
longtemps tu vois
notamment de dire les choses sur la
question des bassines derrière on m'a
bassiné d'ailleurs question qu'on m'a
beaucoup posé
en tous les cas juste pour finir
là-dessus c'est que j'essaye d'être
factuel de dire les choses après les
gens entendent pas mais au moins on n'a
pas un seul discours
qu'on transmet à la population qui
paraît tellement simple et merveilleux
et qui est tellement faux qu'à un moment
donné peut-être couper la tête de ces
systèmes et quand tu coupes la tête de
ça tu as plus une population qui est
complètement sous le joug des
informations qui reçoivent que d'un côté
tu as un autre courant et peut-être que
tu crées quelque chose et alors la
question des bassines elle est simple
c'est que on s'est dit que pour réussir
à
maintenir l'eau on a bien sûr des
barrages on a des ce qu'on appelle des
retenus colinaires c'est-à-dire qu'on va
utiliser le réseau hydrographique
principal donc tu sais c'est l'espèce de
chevelu qui draine chez toi et en fait
tu vas réussir à mettre une sorte de
barrière un mini barrage qui va
permettre de conserver l'eau alors ça
c'est un système qui peut être
intéressant et qui peut soutenir des
petits agricultures locales qui
fonctionnent faut juste faire attention
à un truc c'est que si tu mets des
barrières partout sur tous les cheveux
lus à la fin tu as plus de cours d'eau
donc tout peut être intéressant à
condition de le jauger de manière
intelligente et équilibrée déjà ça c'est
la première chose et c'est loin d'être
le cas deuxième chose la question des
bassines c'est qu'on va prélever
massivement dans l'eau des nappes
phréatique et qu'on va prendre cette eau
qu'on va mettre ensuite en surface dans
des dans des bâches Pvc de une quinzaine
de piscines olympiques à peu près
l'équivalent et on va en mettre un peu
partout
et on va considérer que il faut remplir
cette eau alors l'argument qui est
donnée c'est on prélève le trop-plein
d'hiver pour le conserver pour les
agriculteurs l'été et sur le principe
c'est assez joli sur la carte postale
parce que tu dis mais pourquoi les
pauvres derrière ils ont rien l'été
pourquoi tu leur donnerais pas
finalement ce qu'ils ont l'hiver dans la
réalité c'est un peu plus compliqué
c'est à dire que tu as
une eau qui est prélevée massivement
dans les nappes mais cette eau elle est
censée au printemps
servir à soutenir le cours d'eau
et justement quand le cours d'eau va
être à sec il faut imaginer que quand tu
vois un cours d'eau avec de l'eau et
qu'il a pas plu c'est pas l'eau du cours
d'eau en général c'est l'eau des nappe
sauf quand il y a des canal dérivatifs
etc mais dans la majeure partie c'est la
nappe qui redonne son eau au cours d'eau
qu'on a plus et donc cette équilibre tu
le coupes quand tu prélèves massivement
dans la nappe et c'est pas des petites
quantités et que tu la mets en surface
tu vas déjà créer une déconnexion entre
la nappe et la rivière donc cette
déconnexion fait que la rivière va être
deux fois plus à sec plus rapidement
avec tous l'écosystème qui a autour
alors d'ici là nos poissons derrière
dorment encore heureux avec leur
antidépresseur mais il n'empêche que on
est quand même sur sur ce système
complètement
un peu en sable de déconnecter des
milieux qui étaient connectés entre eux
à des fins d'utilisation superficielle
et tu crées un problème c'est-à-dire que
l'eau que tu vas chercher en profondeur
tu vas la mettre en superficiel et donc
finalement tu vas la soumettre à
l'évaporation massive si tu as crois en
plus le nombre de de vagues de ou de
canicule accélère encore plus le système
et finalement si tu accélères le tout et
ben à un moment donné tu perds entre 20
et 40% d'eau voire parfois plus d'après
certaines études les chiffres sont pas
très clairs dessus mais en tous les cas
un moment donné c'est mathématiques tu
mets de l'eau en superficie elle
s'évapore à partir d'une certaine
température et donc la question c'est
pourquoi à ce moment-là on conserverait
pas cette eau dans les nappes
et on continuerait à prélever dans les
nappes
et le problème c'est que la seule et
unique raison du fait que on crée ces
bassines qui coûtent des millions
d'euros c'est uniquement pour réussir à
dépasser les arrêtés préfectoraux de
crise parce que quand on est en arrêté
préfectoral de crise qu'est-ce qui se
passe et ben on arrête l'irrigation sauf
pour ceux qui ont une bassine donc en
fin de compte tu crées des privilégiés
tous les autres ils ont plus le droit
d'irriguer et en plus tous les autres
eux ils avaient pas les moyens derrière
de se connecter à cette bassine c'est à
dire que tous les autres à l'échelle du
bassin versant parce qu'un bassin
versant c'est c'est important c'est à
dire que tu as enlevé le niveau de la
nappe pour tout le monde tous ceux qui
sont sur cette nappe et des fois les
nappes sont quand même super importantes
et en fin de compte qu'est-ce qui se
passe tous ceux qui avaient un petit
forage derrière peu profond et ben en
réalité eux ils ont plus d'eau deux fois
plus vite et ça c'est le modèle
californien et donc quand on m'a posé la
question dernièrement je disais que je
pense que la France elle continue comme
ça elle ressemblera la Californie dans
10 ans si on continue à mettre des
bassines partout ce qu'on a prévu de
faire d'ailleurs parce que tout le monde
sait collecté en disant il faut
travailler sur le changement climatique
il faut adapter l'agriculture au
changement climatique et à la fin la
solution c'est on va créer des bassines
partout et donc en fait je crois que
derrière faut comprendre que c'est un
système qui court à sa perte et qui suit
le modèle américain et qui suit le
modèle chilien parce que au Chili a
Santiago on a arrêté l'adduction en eau
potable pour les populations parce que
il y a encore 10 ans cultivait
massivement du maïs sauf que du coup on
a ridifié les sols on fait plus rien
pousser on conserve plus l'eau dans les
nappes si on regarde pas ce qui se passe
ailleurs dans la manière dont on a
cultivé le maïs partout on ne comprend
pas ce qui va nous arriver chez nous et
on a peut-être juste un temps d'avance
c'est peut-être ce qui nous rend
finalement plus riche que les autres
derrière d'avoir ces années de recul
pour pouvoir changer très vite donc je
me dis si peut-être qu'on explique les
choses comme ça peut-être qu'on
comprendra que c'est pas possible et
deuxième chose qui est un énorme
mensonge mais c'est un truc de dingue
comme les gens
ça et je veux dire ah ouais ouais c'est
important c'est que on te dit oh là là
il faut il faut vite qu'on prélève cette
eau en fait parce que sinon après elle
part dans les rivières et on l'appelle
on
ose la donner à l'océan
donc du coup pourquoi est-ce que
finalement aujourd'hui je
garderai pas toute l'air qui est autour
de moi parce que j'ai aucune envie
qu'elle aille dans le département d'à
côté ou derrière dans les pays d'à côté
il faut que je la garde donc c'est
exactement la même chose et je comprends
pas comment un argument de cette sorte
peut encore être sorti aujourd'hui en
2022 avec le niveau de connaissance
qu'on a donc voilà j'essaye tu vois de
prendre mon bâton pèlerin et de me dire
au moins s'il y en a certains qui
m'écoutent peut-être que comprendre
derrière qu'on est sur un modèle insensé
ou au moins faut qu'on arrête de mentir
aux gens et je crois que les gens
retrouveront confiance à partir du
moment où on dira les choses et je m'en
suis rendu compte quand j'ai essayé de
mener pas mal d'actions territoriales
d'abord quand on parlait beaucoup du de
la gestion du risque inondation j'avais
des maires qui me disait on veut surtout
pas parler des risques faut surtout pas
dire qu'il y a des zones inondables chez
nous parce que derrière on va faire peur
aux populations et on s'est rendu compte
que quand on expliquait les choses aux
populations qu'on
quand on fait des choses et ben derrière
ça ça marche et localement on peut
recréer des petits écosystèmes recréer
des cycles de l'eau faut jamais oublier
si on parle du cycle de l'eau que 63% de
nos pluies naissent sur les continents
c'est à dire que 34% arrivent de des
masses d'air humide depuis les océans et
les mers mais la plupart de nos pluies
naissent sur les continents ça veut dire
que c'est la manière dont a été aménagé
le continent qui fait qu'on a des pluies
ou pas et c'est plus là qu'on est en
train de perdre en ce moment c'est ce
système qui est en train de d'arriver en
bout de course et finalement de de
d'aridifier tous nos territoires
bon si j'appelle les manuels Macron tout
de suite là on a réussi à avoir son
téléphone privé il se cache mais on a
des ressources donc si on appelle
Emmanuel Macron lui dit voilà
ce sera
Emma Aziza notre ministre de l'écologie
tu fais quoi
je me suis beaucoup posé la question
parce que pas mal de gens non pas du
tout mais c'est une question que je me
suis posée
et en fait je me dis deux choses
j'ai regardé un peu l'expérience Hulot
caca qu'elle apporte il s'est cassé tu
regardes la séquence qui a eu ouais je
veux rentrer dans rien mais là j'ai vu
la séquence derrière le ministre de
l'écologie bon en fait moi il y a un
truc qui m'emmerdrait pour être cash
derrière c'est que j'ai aucune envie
d'être dans une sorte de basse-cour où
ça s'aboie dessus tout le temps quand je
regarde l'Assemblée nationale ça me
désespère donc en fait j'ai je suis trop
rebelle je pense pour être dans un
système comme ça maintenant je me dis si
un moment donné on me donne des
capacités des possibilités j'ai pas
besoin d'être ministre pour ça je m'en
fous du pouvoir je vais pouvoir sur
moi-même c'est déjà énorme mais en fait
si j'ai des capacités de d'action plus
forte que juste ma parole dans les
médias
et ben j'essaierai de
l'utiliserai d'utiliser pour forcer
massivement la transformation des
territoires créer des villes éponges
partout je transformais complètement le
travail sur la résilience alimentaire
tout ce que je t'ai parlé transformer
nos modèles agricoles donner de l'argent
à ce qu'on a besoin disrupter les
modèles pour que on arrête d'engraisser
des systèmes parfois souvent mafieux au
milieu qui soit disant se disent
travailler pour l'écologie et
l'environnement mais en fin de compte
qu'ils prennent juste les financements
qui existent et qui derrière soi-disant
sont juste en train de nous aider mais
non seulement nous aide pas mais font
peur aux Français parce que les gens
n'osent même plus faire des travaux
voilà j'essaierai de faire un système où
l'argent va à cependant besoin que
l'argent sert et qu'on le voit cet
argent passé c'est-à-dire qu'on voit un
moment donné les financements arriver on
voit la chaîne de ceux qui se servent et
on voit qui ça aide et qu'en même temps
on est tous les capteurs de toute la
transformation c'est un des tomber sur
lesquels je travaille en ce moment
massivement une start-up pour ça parce
que j'espère je sais pas si ça
fonctionnera mais en tous les cas
j'espère j'ai envie de croire que on
peut créer des startups sans t-shirt et
basket juste en essayant de de donner
une dimension
juste
altruiste et planétaire a un système
qu'on peut rendre disruptif parce que
c'est pas le modèle de la start-up qui
est intéressant c'est la date le pouvoir
de la data c'est le pouvoir derrière de
de
développement derrière d'outils
numériques qui peuvent permettre de
massifier les choses je pense que tu
vois quand tu regardes le système
doctolib bah ça a permis de
révolutionner complètement notre rapport
au médecin aujourd'hui derrière tu es
plus en train de galérer à passer 300
coups de fil tu regardes qui est
disponible quand tu as besoin de
quelqu'un je crois qu'il faut créer ce
même genre de choses pour la transition
climatique donc j'ai envie d'y croire tu
vois c'est un des derniers projets que
je mène actuellement avec la start-up
que j'ai créée
et je me dis au moins je vais jusqu'au
bout j'ai piger des équipes super et
derrière que j'aime et que du coup voilà
je le fais avec avec un état d'esprit ou
je garde ma liberté je crois en des
systèmes et je sais que les mettre en
application il y a des gens qui se
mettent à y croire de plus en plus
autour de moi qui aime bien peut-être
c'est chouette bah écoute on te suit
j'essaye et puis on verra bien tu vois
derrière ce qui compte c'est qu'on le
fasse
aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de faire cette
interview d'une façon plus light que
sans avec des questions alors combien de
mètres cubes ils ont perdu à gauche pour
pas que ce soit aride
à ils travaillent comme ils
peuvent ils jouent les avec les règles
du jeu il truands pas et il rentre le
soir ils ont des problèmes avec le gamin
et le problème avec leur femme pour le
travail donc on essaye de pas trop être
anxiogène tout de suite tu vois
la donnée la plus anxiogène que toi tu
as brassé ou que tu as utilisé ou que tu
as vu passer dans tes yeux c'était quoi
il y en a un certain nombre il y a
la rivière atmosphérique qui est partie
de
l'Amérique du Sud et qui est arrivée sur
l'Antarctique et qui a fait qu'on a
effacé 1200 km de glace en l'espace de
quelques jours et les plus 40 degrés de
Delta par rapport aux températures
normales c'est quelque chose qui m'a
marqué et en même temps on a eu en plus
un anomalie thermique de plus 30 degrés
en Arctique donc on avait un peu nos
pôles qui chauffaient de toute façon
c'est ce qu'on constate l'épaule
commence à chauffer les le les
anticyclones sont de plus en plus
présents plutôt derrière plus plus bas
dans l'hémisphère Sud et plus haut dans
l'hémisphère Nord
Litton je te dis ça m'a même atteint
psychologiquement je me suis sentie un
peu meurté c'est très dur de se dire
il va avoir des dizaines de morts
et je peux rien faire c'est un sentiment
d'impuissance totale et tu peux appuyer
sur aucun bouton parce qu'en fin de
compte il y a personne qui va t'écouter
à visiteurs alors tu le dis sur Twitter
tu espères que peut-être quelqu'un va
écouter puis finalement tu t'es un peu
désespéré
et puis ben moi je crois que cette année
m'inquiète quand même j'espère que cette
année peut-être cette somme d'éléments
le fait qu'on n'est pas de recharge des
nappes créative le fait qu'on est un
dôme de chaleur on va sans doute vivre
des canicules qui vont suivre peut-être
pour nous faire prendre conscience des
choses j'ai l'impression qu'il en fait
tu tournes la tête à droite tu tournes
la tête à gauche il se passe des choses
partout et puis après tu arrives dans
ton quotidien et tu as tes gamins qui te
demandent de t'aider à faire leurs
devoirs et dans un autre contexte en
fait et il faut répondre à ça il faut
répondre au fait qu'ils ont faim tu vois
on rentre après dans une logique et tu
peux pas garder un moment donné
psychologiquement
être dans un état stable émotionnel
derrière en conservant tout ça donc à
moins tu le prends tu le mets de côté tu
dis ok je le reprends juste après la
seule chose que ça me donne envie tout
ça c'est de continuer à
lire à comprendre apprendre à faire des
corrélations essayer de derrière d'avoir
cette analyse très systémique que
j'essaye à chaque fois d'approcher j'ai
toujours l'impression enfin déjà j'ai
soutenu ma thèse en 2007 tu vois il y a
quand même un certain temps c'était le
l'optimisation du risque de cru éclair
en France aujourd'hui c'est plus qu'en
France mais l'optimisation du système
tant scientifique c'est-à-dire
hydrometrologique que humain c'est à
dire décisionnel et opérationnelle
comment derrière on gère et on optimise
l'alerte la gestion des vies et derrière
cette approche territoriale et ça m'a
beaucoup aidé ma thèse parce que en fait
j'ai disséqué des événements j'ai
disséquer des sur disquettes des images
radars météorologiques et j'analysais
les événements qui s'étaient déroulés
j'ai essayé de comprendre les prises de
décision j'essayais de comprendre à
partir de quand le système s'embalait au
sol à partir de quand il y avait des
morts à partir de quand il y avait des
dégâts et j'ai gardé tout le temps cette
dynamique dans tous les analyses que je
fais aujourd'hui où j'essaye de
comprendre
toutes les corrélations et toutes les
couches toutes les strates qui se
mélangent tant juste les paramètres
physico-chimiques que les paramètres
humains et j'essaye de faire la jointure
entre les deux donc je me dis que la
seule chose que je peux faire et alors
c'est une grande névrose sans doute que
j'ai mais derrière j'ai toujours
l'impression d'être en retard et de pas
avoir lu assez de pas avoir lu parce
qu'il y a toujours des publics
scientifiques qui sortent il y a
toujours des études il y a toujours des
bouquins à l'international enfin partout
et j'essaye de faire des
intercoolation entre tout pour essayer
de comprendre et j'ai l'impression de
jamais assez savoir et puis tu creuses
plus finalement tu sais pas donc ça
t'amène tout le temps dans un niveau de
frustration moi c'est ce qui se passe
pour moi mais mais je continue tu vois
je continue avec cette soif de vouloir
comprendre comprendre apprendre et de me
dire le peu que j'ai compris j'essaie de
le rendre digeste et j'essaye d'en
parler au grand public et je me dis bon
si déjà j'arrive peut-être à faire un
peu ce travail déjà j'ai gagné j'ai
gagné ce que je peux faire dans ma vie
quoi tu vois
c'est déjà pas mal question internet
n'est-ce pas de l'ignorance ou de
l'égoïsme d'avoir fait quatre enfants
j'ai pas toujours fait exprès mais j'ai
assumé tous mes gosses par contre
alors déjà j'en ai que trois mois
vraiment il y en a un 4e que j'élève
mais qui est pas celui que j'ai fabriqué
mais en tous les cas j'essaye d'avoir ce
niveau de responsabilité
et et bon je
sans doute sans doute bon ils sont quand
même assez
âgés pour derrière j'avais peut-être pas
les mêmes niveaux de conscience je les
ai fait plutôt ce qui me permet d'avoir
les mains un peu plus libre et pas dans
les couches aujourd'hui
mais je crois que c'est compliqué de
dire aux gens moi je vois plein de gens
qui me dit j'ai plus envie d'avoir
d'enfants dans ce monde-là mais en fait
c'est notre humanité qui en jeu c'est à
dire que si un moment donné on n'est pas
obligé de se reproduire effectivement
massivement derrière de faire des
grandes familles c'est peut-être
compliqué mais je crois que derrière
c'est aussi important pour des d'essayer
de fonder une famille ça nous donne du
sens ça nous donne envie de nous lever
le matin ça nous donne de l'amour
peut-être qu'on en a besoin c'est
peut-être la seule chose qui nous reste
et ben je trouve que c'est essentiel et
je crois que ça nous nourrit et je sais
pas si c'est l'égoïsme peut-être mais
derrière moi en tous les cas donc
personnel j'ai à chaque fois pas fait
exprès donc en fait j'ai juste assumé
mais je suis la plus heureuse du monde
[Rires]
[Musique]
y a-t-il encore beaucoup de corps
nucopiens dans les observateurs
scientifiques
faut peut-être m'expliquer ce qui est
encore Nicolas je sais pas alors
l'avenir des circuits courts dans la
production locale pour la nourriture
pour la pourrir la population tu crois
qu'il croit pas je crois qu'à ça je
crois qu'à ça je crois que c'est par là
que passera un autre notre système
alimentaire je crois que les en fait on
a mis dans un étau nos agriculteurs et
si aujourd'hui on les manifié si
aujourd'hui on leur donnait du sang si
aujourd'hui on leur permet de nourrir la
population proche moi je sais que fait
beaucoup appel à des produits paysans
locaux tout le temps et enfin de compte
les gens sont fiers et heureux de
pouvoir nous alimenter et bien nous
alimenter nos alimenter avec une rapport
de la santé aussi il nous rapporte du
respect c'est à dire que c'est un
système qui peut marcher qui peut
fonctionner donc moi je c'est un système
dans lequel je crois et je pense même
que c'est le seul avenir qu'on a
aujourd'hui pour fonder notre résilience
alimentaire parce que les gens seront
fiers sont fiers de leur terre il y aura
plus cette antagonisme entre les pros à
gris je crois que faut arrêter à un
moment donné les délires c'est comme les
pronoms nucléaires anti-nucléaires moi
je vois des espèces de débats sur les
réseaux sociaux est-ce qu'on peut pas
sortir de ça sortir de cette dualité
permanente essayez un peu de transcender
ça c'est de rester centré et de dire ok
ça ça fonctionne ça ça fonctionne pas
essayons de voir ensemble et je crois
qu'on peut essayer de créer un nouveau
modèle de société et pour essayer de le
créer je crois qu'il faut le créer à
petit échec alors c'est compliqué quand
t'es parisiens mais je pense qu'il y a
de plus en plus d'AMAP il y a de plus en
plus de systèmes de logique de de
quartier qui favorisent une agriculture
même l'agriculture derrière urbaine
c'est une des solutions qui peut être
intéressante intelligente si on pouvait
avoir des armes fruitiers si vous pouvez
avoir des forêts fruitières j'ai vu que
ça se développe de plus en plus mais
derrière il faut recréer le fait de
pouvoir se nourrir consommer sans pour
autant toujours être dans le système et
peut-être justement mettre à disposition
dans les des fruits des légumes à
disposition que tout le monde peut aller
chercher que qu'on récupérerait oui ou
qui se développe un peu partout loin je
trouve ça magnifique et puis s'adapter
en même temps avec des arbres fruitiers
qui qui s'adaptent à au climat local de
la ville mais en même temps on gagne du
bien-être on gagne tellement sur la
chaîne de valeur que voilà c'est des
modèles qu'il faut promener
est un partisan du corps nucopianisme
c'est-à-dire une personne qui estime que
les innovations technologiques
permettront à l'humanité de subvenir
éternellement ses besoins matériels
eux-mêmes considérés comme une source de
progrès et de développement je comprends
alors moi je trouve
je crois
à retour à la cohérence à la conscience
et au respect des choses et ça passe par
la respect de tous les tous nos cycles
on a beaucoup parlé des limites
planétaires mais le respect de nos sols
le respect de l'eau dans nos sols le
respect de nos cycles on ne respecte
plus nos cycles il y a pas que le cycle
de l'eau il y a le cycle de l'azote le
cycle du phosphore en fait on a pu
respecter le rythme naturel de
renouvellement des choses donc voilà
c'est quelque chose dans lequel je crois
et je crois aussi à l'innovation dans
certaines dans certains cas de figure
j'essaye de suivre un peu toutes les
innovations qui se développent dans le
monde il y a des choses qui sont
intelligentes qu'il faut
mûrir qu'il faut permettre d'aller plus
loin il faut créer des écosystèmes
peut-être en 3D avec du multicultural
derrière tu vois il y a des systèmes en
aquaponie il y a plein de systèmes après
avoir ce qui fonctionne ce qui
fonctionne pas mais en tous les cas des
systèmes qui permettent derrière d'être
rentable au sens de je fais vivre une la
communauté je lui permet de manger c'est
ça la rentabilité la vraie rentabilité
et
en même temps j'agrémente un système
vertueux qui permet de protéger tous ces
gens là je crois et donc et à la fois je
crois beaucoup dans certaines
innovations je crois pas dans toutes les
innovations j'ai un peu du mal avec le
ben vous inquiétez pas on prend la terre
on la dégage et finalement on va sur
mars ce sera beaucoup mieux voilà on
vient de se rendre compte il y avait des
supers séismes sur Mars je suis pas sûr
qu'on soit capable de mieux gérer que
chez nous il y aura peut-être beaucoup
de problèmes alors j'ai l'impression
qu'il y a eu derrière je regardais ça il
y a deux trois jours derrière une
activité majeure peut-être je me trompe
mais il me semble que j'ai vu ça
il y a eu vraisemblablement une activité
forte bon en tous les cas ce que je veux
te dire c'est que je crois que derrière
avant d'aller chercher ailleurs et de
prendre et de jeter je crois qu'on a un
modèle terre qui est plutôt pas mal
quand même parce que derrière on a des
équilibres plutôt fantastique quand tu
regardes à l'échelle propriétaire tu as
des paysages qui sont incroyables je
crois que nos politiques
françaises devraient insister sur le
plan sur le plan géopolitique sur le
fait de mettre des sortes de droit de
veto je sais pas comment ça peut
fonctionner parce que je suis pas du
tout géopolitique et j'ai jamais fait de
politique et donc je mets en tous les
cas essayez de peser de ce qui sont pour
essayer d'arrêter ces systèmes massifs
de déforestation ces systèmes qu'on
entretient nous parce que finalement
je peux pas un moment donné finir par me
dire ça y est c'est fini derrière
l'intérim balle tu vois un moment donné
il faut que j'essaye de trouver des
solutions en tous les cas je me dis que
il y a sans doute certaines inondations
innovations qui sont vraiment
pertinentes et après le reste c'est
beaucoup plus de des systèmes
respectueux qu'il faut recréer
donc il faut trouver un équilibre dans
tout ça mais ça veut dire qu'il faut
changer le système je sais pas si on
sera capable je sais que derrière c'est
système financier qui domine la planète
et j'ai beau essayer de leur dire vous
savez vous devrez vous devrez vous
devriez vous intéresser au sécheresses
parce que derrière vous ça vous
permettrait de comprendre d'où placer
votre argent je suis pas sûr qu'ils en
ait quelque chose à faire mais en tous
les cas j'essaye tu vois ils achètent en
Finlande ils font des bouquets autre
chose dans laquelle je crois beaucoup
pour nous c'est dans la reconversion des
terres la reconversion des terres
abîmées je crois que chaque terre peut
avoir une valeur justement c'est
peut-être
cet impact carbone si tu veux de
séquestration du carbone qui aujourd'hui
se mesure et se monnaie peut-être que
c'est un moyen pour essayer d'aller
prendre des terres détruites et
d'essayer de prôner le fait de
de recréer de nouveaux systèmes en
équilibre avec les populations locales
donc des systèmes aussi social qui
permettent de financer des gens j'ai de
croire que c'est possible
question est une ingénieur hydrologue
lune clé
depuis longtemps mais vas-y
dis-moi ah ouais bah tu vois je suis pas
une ingénieur alors du coup j'avais trop
longtemps que derrière je suis sortie de
fin voilà je suis plus en je sais pas ce
que je cherche mais en tous les cas
j'essaye de chercher je sais pas ce que
j'ai trouvé non plus
des petits nuages blancs avec sa grosse
cheminée le petit croit avec le monde
qui est en train de se dessiner devant
nous
moi j'ai vu un espèce d'engouement
colossal dernièrement
ça s'appelle une porte de sauve qui peut
parce que là ils sont tous en train de
prêcher que le nucléaire c'est vachement
bien mais comme tu es géologues tu sais
que quand tout le marché mondial va
commencer à se mettre à faire du
nucléaire les prix ça va être
je suis surtout hydrologue et en fait du
coup je sais surtout que aujourd'hui en
tous les cas s'appuyait sur des systèmes
aéro et réfrigérant et derrière des
systèmes de cours d'eau et ou bien se
positionner en bordure de mer
avec le risque de submersion marine que
ça comprend derrière c'est pas
anecdotique c'est pas anodin je veux
bien entendre que c'est des carboné je
viens en tant que c'est une solution
rapide efficace je crois qu'il y a
d'autres solutions qu'on peut mettre en
place là je vois que la le Portugal vit
des situations assez terrible parce
qu'on a eu vraiment une chute des débits
des principales rivières et donc de
l'alimentation hydroélectrique depuis le
mois de février et eux ont décidé
massivement d'investir dans le solaire
je crois que il faut qu'on se réveille
un peu
si vu les taux d'ensoleillement et vu le
nombre d'anticyclones qu'on a ce serait
peut-être pas mal d'investir dans le
soleil et dans l'éolien dans certains
couloirs devant parce que en mer du Nord
il y a pas eu de il y a pas eu de vent
l'année dernière donc les éoliennes off
short non pas fonctionné pour les
Pays-Bas donc ça a demandé au Pays-Bas
ensuite d'aller chercher son énergie
finalement je suis sur du gaz naturel
qui est fier au Qatar donc je crois
qu'il faut regarder tout ça
il faut regarder tout ça parce qu'on
comprend aussi une géopolitique qui est
assez intéressante je te donne un autre
exemple que je trouve assez intéressant
c'est la Chine l'année dernière la Chine
avec une de ses pires sécheresses
historique dans le sud de la Chine et en
fait tous ces systèmes
énergétiques se sont écroulés en chaîne
et elle est aussi a fini par aller
chercher du gaz liquéfier naturel dans
les grands métalliques Atari et je crois
que la Chine tout intérêt à avoir des
gazoducs changer d'orientation et aller
vers eux parce que du coup ils se sont
retrouvés de voir fermer deux jours par
semaine leur usine et que dans leur
plaine croissance permanente ils peuvent
pas se le permettre et donc en fait il y
a des choses qui sont en train de te
jouer là j'espère qu'on ne sera assez
lucide pour regarder ce qui se passe et
pour comprendre que effectivement
là il y a quelque chose qui peut se
jouer ici et nous il va falloir
réfléchir très vite à peut-être d'autres
solutions
je parle très vite
en termes de temps on a combien de temps
avant que ça a vraiment ça parte en
chaussette je vais sortir de ce qui
s'est raconté dans le dernier rapport du
GIEC qui disait que derrière la
trajectoire climatique à 3 ans derrière
parce que ça pas été compris donc en fin
de 3 ans mais c'est pas 3 ans c'est 3
ans pour pas atteindre les 1 degré et
demi mais en réalité on a plus de temps
moi je crois qu'on a pas de temps je
crois qu'il faut agir maintenant mais je
pense que si dans les trois gens trois
ans pardon on agit massivement on a
peut-être une chance d'essayer de mettre
en place un système
végétal agricole transformation des
terres de récupération de humus de
matières organiques même si un seul ça
met 1000 ans pour être derrière de
qualité on est en train de perdre nos
sols massivement toutes les études le
montrent on a de l'érosion enfin bon je
pars au rentrer dans les trucs
angoissant parce que je crois qu'on a
déjà fait le tour d'un panel assez clair
mais
alors ben écoute je je pense que si on
arrive dans les trois ans qui viennent à
agir
ce qui arrive devant nous pourrait pas
être limité mais on pourrait un peu
freiner ce système qui est plus
exponentiel qu'autre chose
donc
j'ai tendance à me dire que si on
comprend ce que l'on a devant nous faut
demain
changer le modèle c'est-à-dire demain il
faut arrêter les pesticides alors on va
dire mais attendez derrière c'est
comment on appelle ça c'est la la
production alimentaire de la France
derrière on est la souveraineté
alimentaire on maintient la souveraine
alimentaire c'est ce qui est quand même
souvent évoqué non c'est pas vrai on
soutient le fait de nourrir du bétail
peut-être qu'on devrait soutenir le fait
de nous nourrir nous
bétail
non non je parle de je pense que
derrière on devrait nous nourrir nous
nourrir avant tout nous mais cette
souveraineté alimentaire en entretenant
ce modèle agricole il est terrible il
court à notre perte et derrière il a été
exploité partout là où aujourd'hui on a
de la réalité massive il faut jamais
oublier que le Croissant fertile le
tigre et le frotte toute la péninsule
arabique c'était
zone luxuriante où on a démarré une
agriculture très tôt on a été chercher
en profondeur des eaux salées avec un
peu de cyanure au passage souvent et qui
derrière ont modifié la qualité des sols
et on arrive ici au fur et à mesure les
territoires alors ça on a eu le temps on
a mis 2000 3000 ans pour voir cette
aridification qui s'est mis en place je
là vu l'accélération du système on est
de toutes les façons sur quelque chose
qui est en train de se jouer beaucoup
plus rapidement en termes de dynamique
et donc du coup ce qui est clair c'est
que ces systèmes peuvent plus continuer
en fait aujourd'hui on y régle les
vignes on est réglé les villes qui sont
non non pas du tout derrière on a trouvé
ce super moyen on a pris un canal
derrière on s'est dit génial derrière on
peut récupérer de l'eau et donc on va
arrêter de finalement de s'emmerder j'ai
envie de dire avec ses problèmes qu'on
avait derrière de sécheresse on a trouvé
une solution le problème c'est que les
vignes deviennent feignantes les racines
remontent et donc en fin de on se
retrouve avec un système qui à bout de
souffle et on a créé l'inverse de la
résilience on a créé de la vulnérabilité
si demain on a plus cette adduction par
l'eau de ce canal et ben demain derrière
les vignes meurent direct parce qu'elles
tiennent pas donc voilà je crois que
c'est un peu cette petite vie elle est à
l'image de nos systèmes sur alimenter
par par de l'irrigation permanente
de nos systèmes et voilà si on arrête
peut-être d'irriguer on va peut-être
mettre nos racines un peu plus
profondément sur l'essentiel et
peut-être qu'on aura plus besoin de ce
qui paraît superflu quoi un PDG d'une
très grosse boîte Suisse dit bon alors
loup gratuit maintenant c'est terminé
besoin privatisé c'est pas bien public
tu as entendu ce genre de déclaration
non tu as pas vu passer ce truc là j'ai
suivi la question de l'eau en bourse
californienne déjà donc de la
financearisation de l'eau qui est une
vraie question c'est intéressant comment
tout ce que l'on tous nos éléments
deviennent monétisables
bientôt demain c'est l'air qu'on respire
qu'on nous fera payer sans doute
qu'est-ce que tu veux que je te dise de
plus que derrière il y a il y a aucune
cohérence je crois que derrière
je sais derrière qu'on a un système sur
lequel on s'appuie toujours un peu plus
sur le fait de monétariser
un équilibre qui est là et on va le
prendre on va se l'approprier on va se
dire qu'il est à nous et on va oublier
complètement
la réalité du vivant du monde et
appliquant qui le dise plus que moi
derrière et je suis pas spécialiste en
biodiversité mais quand tu vois ces
effondrements massifs à un moment donné
il faut comprendre c'est qu'il y a la
fin c'est comme à la TVA on est au bout
de la chaîne c'est nous qui payons c'est
pareil parce que tu as vu le film
là où le jour là où la planète
s'arrêtera c'est ça
non je l'ai pas vu je regarde quasiment
jamais la télé et je regarde pas de film
je fais de guerre des livres ou des
publications donc ou des thèses mais je
dis moi
ça va me revenir à la communauté
et donc la machine la marchandise
marchandises tu m'as compris et ça c'est
exclusé est-ce que tu penses que la
coiffure du Tchad va créer des problèmes
avec les pays locaux est-ce que on va
encore se voir
encore avec des guerres de loups
alors pour le moment
s'arrêtera pour le moment ça se joue par
dissuasion
c'est à dire que c'est souvent le pays
le plus fort qui dissuade l'autre de
vouloir demander un peu trop d'eau
l'Égypte et l'Éthiopie par exemple tu
vois l'Éthiopie a beaucoup d'eau elle
est à la montre du bassin l'Egypte est
en bas mais l'Égypte est un peu plus
forte et un peu plus armée que
l'Éthiopie donc du coup maintenant que
l'Éthiopie manque d'eau ils ont envie de
garder leur eau pour eux mais on leur
fait comprendre que cette eau-là
normalement elle a été prévue pour Laval
donc pour le moment ça se joue quand
même plutôt
dans des solutions diplomatiques pas
toujours pas toujours mais en tous les
cas la solution diplomatique elle est
très simple c'est le plus fort qui gagne
c'est très simple
après il y a la question de la guerre de
l'eau et des conflits de l'eau à
l'intérieur des pays c'est des choses
qu'on a beaucoup étudié travailler
sur des pays en Afrique du Nord dans
différents
justement entre les différents systèmes
sociétaux et à analyser
le concept même de cette question de
l'eau de l'eau qui paraît arriver
finalement tombé du ciel c'est un cadeau
divin et donc en réalité celui qui l'a
est riche et l'utilise c'est un peu
genre de florais tu vois l'idée c'est
que et donc celui qui l'a ne va pas
penser spécialement aux autres et
surtout Manon des Sources exactement je
dis surtout c'est ça c'est la suite et
donc en fait
je vois arriver cette guerre de l'an en
France
parce que dans une pénurie qu'on
commence à avoir
et bien tu as les systèmes industriels
j'ai besoin de beaucoup d'eau derrière
même si c'est les circuits de
refroidissement c'est utiliser quand
même massivement à un moment donné
derrière pour refroidir donc ça veut
dire que l'eau elle arrive avec une
certaine température donc tu as toujours
cette question du milieu et secteur et
il y a quand même une police assez bien
organisé là-dessus en France on n'est
pas capable aujourd'hui d'avoir un bon
état écologique des cours d'eau 40% nos
nappes sont dans un état médiocre nos
rivières c'est pas mieux mais au moins
au moins on essaie de contrôler la
température des rivières
mais tu te confrontes à plusieurs choses
tu te confrontes à l'eau domestique
l'eau des villes l'eau industrielle
l'eau des agriculteurs et pour le moment
la France dit la priorité des priorités
c'est l'adduction d'eau potable des
populations c'est-à-dire que les arrêts
préfectoraux en face de crise t'arrête
l'irrigation tu arrêtes de laver ta
voiture t'arrêtes la piscine mais
derrière on garde l'adduction en eau
potable dans d'autres pays on a diminué
de 25% je pense à Californie et
au Chili on a diminué de 25% la quantité
de de possible pour les populations donc
en fait ils ont l'obligation de diminuer
leur quantité d'eau mais on a absolument
pas diminué pour les agriculteurs alors
qu'en France on vise d'abord les
agriculteurs qui arrêtent l'irrigation
qui génèrent ce problème de bassine
d'ailleurs parce que sinon il y aurait
pas s'il y avait pas ces arrêts
préfectoraux il y aurait pas de problème
de massif donc
voilà pour essayer de brosser un peu le
portrait question internet aujourd'hui
combien de temps en moyenne se
passe-t-il entre la découverte d'une
information liée au climat ou à l'état
des réserves de l'eau sa diffusion dans
le milieu scientifique son acceptation
par la majorité scientifique des
scientifiques
idem pour les médias et les citoyens
deux ans ou large 5 ans 10 ans je pense
que chaque publication scientifique en
général fait l'objet d'une information
dans la presse je le vois pour les
limites planétaires et la revue la
publication d'un nature sur la 6ème
limite dépassée de l'eau douce qui était
l'eau verte je crois que une publicité
lorsqu'elle est importante est en
général relayée par un ensemble de
médias immédiatement et même rendu
digeste par un ensemble de médias c'est
juste que les constats on les fait on
les fait on les fait et après il se
passe rien c'est juste ça mais
l'information a tendance à se diffuser
ce que je trouve dommage
par contre il y a des gens qui font des
thèses trois quatre ans et qui donne
tout ce qu'ils ont pour derrière essayer
d'analyser d'aborder un sujet à fond et
ta maximum 10 personnes
qui liront cette thèse alors que c'est
une mine d'information colossale pour
trouver des solutions et moi j'aime
beaucoup essayer de lire les tests qui
sortent parce qu'elles sont accessibles
en ligne et j'aime essayer de comprendre
s'il y a des choses qui pourraient
m'inspirer dans des solutions qu'on
pourrait préconiser et je crois qu'on
devrait faire ça à l'échelle
internationale
tu on va te faire revenir
parce que c'est un sujet qui est
cerise sur le gâteau c'est la goutte
d'eau qui fait déborder le vase pour
nous c'est donc il faut absolument que
tu écrives un livre je suis en train je
suis en train mais j'ai tellement passé
de temps sur le terrain que je sais pas
le temps en général donc
tu vas revenir
nous refaire un topo plus en détail sur
les pesticides qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans
l'eau qu'est-ce qui nous et tout un tas
de choses on va te poser encore deux
trois questions avant de te relâcher on
va se boire une bière
quel impact du confinement sur le climat
est-ce que tu as eu des des données
passées est-ce que le fait qu'on soit
tous enfermer ça a aidé un peu la nature
on l'a tous vu des dauphins à Venise on
a tous vu revenir des renards on savait
même plus qu'ils existaient derrière des
sangliers dans les rues je crois que à
un moment donné le vivant reprend sa
place à partir du moment où tu le
laisses de l'espace c'est-à-dire que
l'homme a tellement pris toutes les
niches écologiques tous les milieux qui
a plus aucun espace pour pour le reste
tous nos dérange tout est un nuisible
même une herbe elle devient mauvaise
alors qu'une herbe c'est magnifique en
fait elle passe son temps à transpirer
l'eau qu'elle a pour essayer de capter
le carbone enfin c'est juste un système
merveilleux et on considère que c'est
des mauvaises herbes et on a mis des
coups de Run top partout on pouvait pour
derrière protéger assainir on a enlevé
jusqu'à 80% de nos eaux humides en
France c'est à dire qu'on a enlevé cette
capacité de notre terre à garder l'eau
et à permettre ces boucles de
rétroaction pour avoir nos pluies donc
en fait on paye d'ailleurs la question
du fait que on a le changement
climatique qui est là que nous même on a
créé que nous-mêmes on alimente en local
par la manière dont on a aménagé et en
fin de compte on est tu parlais de
sandwichs c'est nous qui sommes
actuellement en sandwich entre ce qu'on
a créé et ce qu'on se prend en plus que
les autres ont créé enfin tu vois ça
crée une sorte d'inertie donc
voilà je sais plus quelle était ta
question là ça commence à
la bière va être nécessaire
tu as été à Notre-Dame-des-Landes
question internet peut-on avoir
confiance en la potabilité de notre roue
plutôt oui je pense parce que derrière
je vois comment ça fonctionne et je
trouve que on a de l'eau potable qui est
plutôt qualitative on a des vrais
problèmes de réseau des vrais problèmes
de fuite des vrais problèmes de métaux
lourds on a des systèmes de filtration
maintenant à l'échelle locale qui sont
de plus en plus diffusées il faut qu'en
fait on essaie de solution là pour qu'on
arrête d'acheter des bouteilles en
plastique parce que c'est pas un système
soutenable
éventuellement garder la qualité de nos
eaux thermominéral parce que derrière
c'est ce qui fait aussi la fabrique de
la France il faut savoir que les eaux
minérales aux États-Unis ce sont des os
qui sont quasiment distillées c'est à
dire que le principe d'une eau de
qualité aux États-Unis c'est qu'elle
n'est rien alors que le principe chez
nous c'est qu'elle soit remplie de
minéraux voire même un peu de Flore etc
qui viennent constituer notre microbiote
tu vois d'ailleurs en parlant de
microbiote c'est bien parce que je vois
depuis plusieurs années qui prend de
l'espace derrière dans la compréhension
de ce que l'on est présentation modifie
le microbiote d'une souris avec une
autre espèce on change son caractère on
change sa façon d'être on change la
manière dont elle va stocker ses
graisses etc c'est intéressant et ben
peut-être qu'on devrait faire le
parallèle d'ailleurs avec nos sols on
est en train dans lever le microbiote et
on est en train de tuer tout partout
dans nos sols imagine que nous si on tue
notre microbiote on serait on tiendrait
pas une heure quoi donc la masse
d'animaux qui est dans le sol représente
je sais pas combien de fois plus de ce
qu'il y a il me semble que c'est un
quart des espèces planétaires qui sont
dans nos sols
question internet que pense-t-elle des
habitats alternatifs quitter les villes
pour aller vivre dans la nature pour
l'interrogation
à condition de pas pourrir la nature ça
peut être des solutions qui peuvent être
magnifiques si on déporte le problème
avec nos modes de fonctionnement
ailleurs je suis pas sûr que on résout
on réussit à résolve à résoudre un
problème mais que derrière on en crée
d'autres donc si on est dans cette dans
ce respect dans cette logique
effectivement plus on va se connecter à
la nature plus on sera résilié
bon la prochaine fois on parle à
fracturation hydraulique qui est tout un
tas de choses question d'internet en
plus de ces trois livres de la fin donc
on va te demander trois livres
peut-on lui demander trois souhaits
et un conseil pour les jeunes
générations alors trois livres pour nous
pourra conseiller pour notre communauté
à trois livres
moi j'ai bien aimé je le trouve très
vulgarisé mais très intéressant
j'imagine que Ton a peut-être déjà parlé
mais le bug humain de Sébastien Bauler
j'aime bien le lien qui fait entre
entre nos cerveaux et derrière notre
manière de concevoir et de continuer
dans un système sans fin ce que je
trouvais que c'était intéressant de mais
les neurosciences et questions
climatiques et la planète
trois livres
je j'aurais tendance à conseiller
peut-être le livre de Daniel Zimmer qui
parle de l'empreinte o moi il m'a
beaucoup nourri
parce que derrière ça m'a permis de
comprendre
encore un peu plus en profondeur la
manière dont se cache la question de
l'eau et après je citerai
Eric Orsenna et le Livre qu'il a fait il
a fermé sur le coton il a fait aussi un
livre sur la question de l'eau et c'est
un classique mais je le trouve assez
merveilleux parce que du coup on a un
voyage dans le monde et ça nous permet
de voir finalement comment est géré
notre eau et j'aime beaucoup son passage
sur la question australienne c'est
intéressant de regarder la manière
notamment donné il prend du recul il
regarde des grands ronds comme ça autour
des cours d'eau sur les cartes en
Australie ça me fait penser à nos
bassines et puis surtout parce que j'ai
fait une conférence avec lui la semaine
dernière je l'ai rencontré je l'ai
trouvé merveilleux et que et que ça nous
fait du bien d'avoir des d'avoir de
l'humanité et que et que c'est peut-être
ça qui nous reste avant de te demander
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
je vais passer encore deux questions
est-il pertinent de croire pouvoir
changer un système le système de
l'Intérieur vu comment il se structure
et des intérêts défendus par de nombreux
par nombreux de ses acteurs où est-il
plus pertinent de déserter et de
construire quelque chose de mieux à son
échelle tel que nous invite à le faire
ces étudiants d'agroaritech dernièrement
que pensez-vous du changement du PDG de
Danone de l'an dernier
je suis pas sûr qu'il faille tout ce
qu'on vive dans un eco-village je pense
qu'on aurait des problèmes de voisinage
des problèmes de gestion qui
arriveraient aussi parce qu'on est resté
humain
je pense que ça peut être des solutions
intéressantes mais je pense que c'est
plus intéressant d'essayer de changer
les choses là où on est et qu'on peut
faire des choses donc moi j'ai envie d'y
croire et de me dire que c'est un autre
échelle qu'il faut changer des choses on
va en profiter pour placer le
documentaire de Nicolas Mérieux et de
Sophie Labruyère nouvelle graine sur
reprendre des thés en Renault culture
pour réenrichir les sols et c'est dispo
sur France télévish
André celos qui nous parle de la qualité
des sols et qui nous montre ce monde
incroyable je l'ai pas cité parce que le
livre est peut-être un peu très
technique mais à la fois c'est
fantastique de découvrir cette richesse
qu'on a de nos sols voilà je pense que
de toutes les façons on se baladant à
travers tellement de livres on comprend
tellement de choses que ça ça ouvre
notre SCOP et puis ça nous permet de
faire des interactions avec tout quoi
ce que tu as un conseil pour les jeunes
générations une bouteille à la mer
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
d'essayer peut-être
[Musique]
de c'est compliqué parce que tu as deux
types de générations tu as la génération
qui manifeste dans la rue et qui a
l'impression que tu lui as volé son
avenir puis tu as la génération qui est
sur Instagram et qui derrière et
concentré sur les instagramurs et sur le
dernier
rouge à lèvres tu vois c'est compliqué
je dirais que faut pas perdre espoir il
faut rester dans ce il faut essayer que
chacun va peut-être ça il faudrait
essayer que chacun trouve son pourquoi
parce qu'on a tous on peut tous trouver
un pourquoi un moment donné on se lève
le matin
et si on l'a pas c'est important de le
chercher parce que quand on le trouve ça
nous donne ce désir de nous lever
d'avancer ça nous donne du sens et peu
importe où on va ça nous appartient pas
où on va la seule chose qui nous
appartient c'est nous et donc
j'essaierai de dire à cette jeunesse que
il faut lâcher toutes les peurs de ses
adultes
tous ces systèmes d'oppression on nous a
mis dans des cases dans des modèles
derrière partout pour tout que ce soit
nous que ce soit le maïs tout ce que
l'on a construit a été construit sur un
monomodel j'ai l'impression qu'on a fait
des monocultures tu regardes les écoles
les collèges les lycées voilà jusqu'au
bac et puis derrière je crois que voilà
c'est peut-être faire avec le système
danser avec le système sans jamais lui
appartenir
je crois que c'est ça la solution ce que
j'essaye de faire
[Musique]